hello everyone welcome to the september
2021 ask me anything edition of the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll this episode is being brought to
you from the mindscape mobile podcasting
unit currently located in boston
massachusetts rather than my usual home
base of los angeles uh with the pandemic
clearing up a little bit though
obviously not entirely
travel is once again possible and as
some of you know i'm spending the fall
semester visiting the philosophy
department at harvard harvard was
my graduate institution but i was in the
astronomy department i did though take
some philosophy courses because i was
interested in philosophy at the time so
i got to sit on courses
with john rawls and robert nozick and
other people and uh some of you have
heard this question because this
anecdote before but i got to know john
rawls i chatted with him very famous
social moral political philosopher
and it turns out that he's really really
interested in physics and cosmology
so you know he asked me because he was
very fair right john rolls's whole
shtick was justice as fairness and
happily this doesn't always happen
especially with moral philosophers but
john rawls walked the walk as well as
talking the talk he was a scrupulously
fair guy i remember once uh walking
through harvard yard and running into
some of my friends who were in the
philosophy class and i was just auditing
it and they were taking it for real so
they had just gotten out of the
final exam and i said so how was it and
they said you know what it was very fair
and a friend of mine who was with me
immediately said those must be your
philosophy friends i've never heard a
physics person say that their final exam
was fair
so anyway yes john rawls was all about
fairness and so i asked him even though
i was just auditing the class could i go
to the
section discussions you know the small
group discussions which were led by him
and he said you know the rule is if
you're a graduate student you can go to
those sections you're a graduate student
therefore you can go scrupulously fair i
was hoping to talk to him about
philosophy and fairness and things like
that but once he heard that i was a
cosmologist it was all over he's like oh
you do that alan guth stuff and so
whenever we met he would ask me
questions about the big bang or things
like that different things in both
mathematics and physics i remember very
well um once in class he was lecturing
and he used the analogy you know proving
this is kind of like proving stokes's
theorem on an arbitrary differentiable
manifold once you set up all the
definitions the actual steps are very
very simple i'm sure no one else in the
class understood the power of that
analogy but i thought it was a very good
one for me so anyway it's nice to be
back
as an official
person in the philosophy department um
hopefully i just started so i haven't
done anything yet but part of my
motivation here was to learn a little
bit more about things like emergence
and uh
mathematics philosophy of mathematics
different questions in logic and
causation and things like that but i
will also confess that while i'm here
i'll be hanging out with my old friends
physics and astronomy as well as friends
at mit and elsewhere it's a real
tremendous number of intellectual
resources here around boston so i hope
it'll be a lot of fun
uh and with that we have a whole bunch
of ama questions i think that the
quality of questions is going up now
that we don't answer every one of them
you remember the rules uh i will answer
a certain number of questions it's
nothing to do with the quality of the
question you're asking what the
criterion is is do i have something
interesting to say about it but people
are definitely aiming their questions a
little bit better now that i can't do
every one they're definitely trying to
get in there i do feel really bad for
those who are not able to ask
questions sorry about that for those of
you who are wondering how to ask
questions this is a benefit that you get
from joining the mindscape patreon
page so if you support on patreon one
dollar per episode or more that's up to
you uh you can ask questions for the
amas and then you also get ad-free
versions of the podcasts so that's a
nice thing to do patreon.com sean m
carroll the biggest benefit of course is
the feeling of happiness that you're
supporting something that you enjoy
that's something that we can all get
behind
and with that lots of questions so let's
go
[Music]
michael gordon says during your aip oral
history interview in january which for
those of you who don't know i did a long
interview
basically about my career in physics etc
and that we posted as a bonus podcast
episode back in january uh michael says
you expressed a wish to move toward a
world where judgment was passed more
directly on the merit of the ideas in
some opposition to the current
environment of specialization and
departmental segregation of ideas can
you share more specifically why you
believe a shift may be needed here what
you would like to see change and if you
know of any rigorous work being done in
this area that quantifies how what how
and what is lost in the process of
specialization
um so these are big you know difficult
questions and i'm probably not
an expert in them you know in the sense
that i'm in academia and i do work and i
do interdisciplinary work i'm familiar
with some of the issues but then i know
very well familiarity is not enough to
make one an expert so take anything i
say with a grain of salt but
look i mean the first thing to say is
that the current system actually does
work quite well
uh we get a lot of research done we
discover a lot of things about the
universe you know there are literally
things like science week in review you
can go see all the scientific advances
that have just happened this week
whereas a thousand years ago there
weren't many scientific advances every
week at all
the current academic slash research
system is pretty darn good at producing
new useful research but that doesn't
make it perfect and i think that it's
true that one of the ways in which it
falls down is that it organizes itself
the whole academic research industrial
complex or whatever you want to call it
organizes itself in some way like many
institutions do and that weighs
typically into fields or departments in
a university so you have physics you
have biology you have chemistry you have
history you have english you have
philosophy and so forth and these in the
in the modern university these
departments are largely self-sustaining
so the dean or the president of the
provost will say okay
you can have this many new faculty
members over the next five years but
roughly speaking the departments have 98
of the responsibility to hire the new
faculty members and to choose what areas
they want to hire in there are some rare
exceptions but that's the usual rule so
as a result it is kind of
self-perpetuating the physicists choose
physicists you know the biologists
choose biologists and so the people who
are working in areas that are instantly
recognizable as not only good but also
friendly to the notions of the
discipline are easier sells for people
who to hire than people who work at the
boundaries because different disciplines
have very different standards very
different ideas of what problems are
interesting how much you should have
published and all this kind of stuff is
different because you have a whole bunch
of informal
customs and rules that grow up not just
formal bits of knowledge i have an
upcoming interview you will hear soon
with someone who is who feels very
fervently that this is bad and you know
it's caused us to not do as good
research as we can and i think that's
right you know i think that human beings
are finite in their abilities to to do
things uh you know you've heard that
whether it was in my interview with carl
fristen or stephen wolfram we're
computationally bounded so we don't
optimize things like a university to be
perfect we sort of have finite resources
and we deal with them in a finite kind
of way it's easy and fairly effective to
just organize departments and then be
gone with it but then you miss
opportunities at the interfaces so that
does open the opportunity for places
like the santa fe institute to do
cross-cutting interdisciplinary work and
of course many administrators at
universities give lip service to the
importance of it uh but at most
universities when they start putting
their money where their mouths are it's
harder to actually do um so i actually
don't know how to really
solve it you know i think that
the current system like i said is pretty
good
i don't want to overthrow it wholesale
so the least we can do is just remind
our colleagues of the importance of
looking a little bit beyond their
disciplinary boxes you know as long as
it is faculty members in departments who
hire new faculty members the single best
thing you can do
to
broaden the horizons of university
departments is to broaden the horizons
of individual faculty members so say
that interdisciplinary work is good but
also do good interdisciplinary work
right if you can point to something and
say look at this result that we got
because we were thinking in an
interdisciplinary way and you weren't
that's what will really change people's
minds
charlie shaffer says from listening to
you and reading your books you suggest
that the universe is ultimately
understandable to the human mind my
question is how do you speculate on that
knowledge buildup and how does that
final attainment of that understanding
play out giving the seemingly immense
time scale of the universe do we have a
continual buildup of knowledge is there
always room for new discovery or do we
need to rebuild era after era uh this is
a great question there's a lot of stuff
going on here so i i will have to
refrain myself from doing a whole solo
podcast about this uh but the point is
that you know it's not quite accurate to
compare our knowledge of the universe to
the size of the universe right or the
immense time scale of the universe
because when we learn about the universe
we don't just learn a collection of
facts we're not just collecting every
individual thing that happened in the
history of the universe that would be
hopeless we're collecting rules we're
collecting patterns and it seems to be a
feature of the universe that it obeys
these patterns and you can think of
these patterns as
compressions of all of the different
ways all the different events that
happen in the universe
this is a human
following david hume a humane view on
what the laws of physics are they are
just very very compact restatements of
everything that happens in the universe
but again it seems empirically from our
experience that you need a small number
of laws of physics and a small number of
fundamental ingredients to account
ultimately for everything that we see so
i don't i'm not worried about the
immense time scale or anything like that
it's quite the opposite i am enormously
shocked at how far we have gotten in
understanding how the universe works uh
right now now there's another there's a
footnote here that is worth talking
about if you if you're interested you
can go back to the podcast i did with
james ladyman who's a philosopher who
was one of the champions of what is
called structural realism
um because you say at the end charlie uh
do we need to rebuild air era after era
and there is sort of a school of thought
in the philosophy of science that says
exactly that right um some version of
thomas coon's structure of scientific
revolutions
picture says that we have a paradigm
that we work within and then ultimately
the paradigm is overthrown in a
revolution and the new paradigm comes in
and sees things in a completely
different way
the structural realist ladyman and his
friends will say there is something that
is preserved when we throw away the old
picture and get the new one in and it is
the structure
somehow the even though the ontology
might be different the actual
fundamental ingredients so when you go
from
newtonian physics to relativity or from
classical physics to quantum mechanics
your ontology changes in a profound way
but still both general relativity and
newtonian physics give you more or less
the same prediction for when the next
lunar eclipse or solar eclipse is going
to be right
that kind of structure those
relationships between what you observe
is preserved over time and so the
hardcore structural realists will say
that those those structures those
relations are all that exists there's no
real stuff that we're studying we're
just studying the relationship between
i guess different observations you know
if you if you say you're studying
relationships
structures between things there need to
be things in some sense but i haven't
completely understood this myself
so there are
on-tech structural realists who think
that the structural realism point of
view is really a statement about what
exists there's also epistemological or
epistemic structural realists who think
that this statement is just a statement
of what we can know about the universe
so i think i'm closer to an epistemic
structural realist um so but the point
is even if
we keep learning completely new
vocabularies with which to describe the
world that doesn't mean we're starting
again that doesn't mean rebuilding we're
keeping something uh along the way
okay i'm gonna group a bunch of
questions together we got a lot of
questions about entropy in the arrow of
time unsurprising because we had that
wonderful podcast with david wallace so
let me just read a whole bunch of
questions and i'll do my best to say
something interesting about them
nate says is there any interesting
relationship between cosmological
inflation or expansion and entropy in
particular could expansion or inflation
be changing the entropy capacity of the
universe pair magnuson says you've said
many times that the presence of gravity
made the entropy of the big bang low can
you give an intuitive explanation for
how gravity has this effect
reiner gluga says is entropy not just an
epiphenomenon of sufficiently complex
systems and hence not very fundamental
it may for example not be reasonable to
speak about the entropy of the early
universe if there were not enough
degrees of freedom to apply an entropy
concept
john bergmeyer says when you discuss the
early universe having low entropy how is
that possible
i don't have an intuitive idea of what
that would look like since all the
typical low entropy examples unmelted
ice cube etc still have a pretty high
entropy and many different possible
micro states
uh nate wadoops says in your
conversation with david wallace you said
it truly blows my mind that even to this
day the reason why ice cubes melt and
don't done melt has something to do with
what was going on 14 billion years ago
at the big bang could you elaborate i'm
well aware that ice cubes do not unmelt
but i'm unaware of how that might stem
from something that was going on 14
billion years ago
okay let's take these not quite in
reverse order but let's start with uh
nate wadoops's question uh i guess
there's another
nate just nate without a last name who
has the first question so because this
is the most basic one what is this
relationship of what is happening at the
big bang to the fact that ice cubes melt
but don't unmelt
it's not that ice cubes don't unmelt
that is being explained here the fact
that ice cubes don't unmelt just comes
from the fact that an unmelted ice cube
is lower entropy which means there are
far fewer ways to arrange water
molecules in a glass of water in the
form of warm water plus ice cube
then there are just every uh everything
is cool water or something like that
okay so sitting by itself it's not going
to spontaneously go from a cool glass of
water with no ice cube to warm glass of
water plus ice cube so just to emphasize
this the numbers are that we're talking
about here are really really big you
know i think that uh if you haven't done
these calculations yourself and people
say well this is unlikely this is going
to come up later again when we talk
about quantum mechanics
over and over again people say well this
is unlikely physicists say the following
thing is unlikely and you can't help but
think well see you're saying there's a
chance it's possible if you're saying it
unlikely it could be possible right
well yeah but really really really
unlikely if you you know converted all
the atoms in the universe to ice cubes
and glasses of water and waited much
much much longer than the age of the
universe the chance that any one of
those ice cubes would unmelt is
very very very small okay over the whole
history of the universe so it's not
something where occasionally it will
happen all right having said all that
preliminary
what is being explained by the big bang
is that there ever were unmelted ice
cubes
that's the mystery the mystery is not
why you go from some configuration like
an ice cube in a glass of water and it
melts
the mystery is given that there is a
cool glass of water
why is it even plausible
that there used to be a warm glass of
water with an ice cube in it that's a
much lower entropy state it's not the
easiest way to get to a current
configuration that looks like a cool
glass of water and that's what is
explained by the big bang the big bang
itself was a state with very very low
entropy
uh in the core screening that we human
beings use to understand the universe
the state of the degrees of freedom in
the early universe was highly highly
special highly highly atypical very very
low entropy
and it's the gradual increasing of the
entropy since the big bang which is very
natural right
that allows us to have ice cubes along
the way and watch them melt if it
weren't for that boundary condition at
the big bang
either you know depending on what else
you conditionalize on either there just
wouldn't be any ice cubes in the
universe the universe would be in
equilibrium which is just empty space
and nothing going on
or whenever there was an ice cube the
future and the past of that ice cube
would look the same namely a glass of
cool water without any ice cube in it
that's the easiest way to get
an ice cube uh is to just sort of take a
glass of cool water and wait
it's very very unlikely it will turn
into an ice cube but it's so many more
possible starting points that you still
win on the number of starting points
there okay
so there
if you understood that hopefully you did
but other people john for example is
asking um
in what sense is the entropy of the
early universe low
and nate says i'm sorry pair magnuson
says um
what does gravity have to do with
entropy being low at the big bang so if
you look at the state of the early
universe and the big bang um it looks
kind of high entropy it looks like a
thermal black body smooth hot dense
state right and if you had a box of gas
and it was glowing with thermal
blackbody radiation you would say that's
high entropy
so it's not that gravity made the
entropy of the big bang at the big bang
low it's that near at the big bang that
early time gravity was important
it's a big universe there's a lot of
matter in it the universe is much bigger
than the boxes of gas that you're used
to doing in a laboratory experiment okay
so in the box of gas in the laboratory
we just ignore gravity we ignore the
gravity
pulling one gas molecule by another gas
molecule the earth's gravity still
matters but the intra intra yeah
intramolecular gravity in the box
doesn't matter at all whereas in the
universe it matters a lot in particular
if you ask yourself are there ways to
arrange the stuff in the early universe
such that the entropy would be much
higher the answer is clearly yes and
roger penrose former mindscape guest uh
recent nobel prize winner was the one
who really emphasized this you know
starting back in the 1970s but he's
emphasized it many times since then
a single black hole at the center of our
galaxy right you know there's a black
hole
in the center of our galaxy sagittarius
a millions of times the mass of the sun
that has an entropy we can calculate
that entropy um using stephen hawking's
formula and beckenstein in hawking
and that single black hole has more
entropy than the entire universe had at
early times okay so clearly it's
possible to take the stuff in the early
universe and put it into a higher
entropy state just putting in a single
black hole would be way way way higher
entropy okay that's why gravity really
really matters um
and that is why you can't say to get to
nate's question
um expansion or inflation increases the
entropy capacity of the universe this is
a very this is a very intuitive thing i
know why you would think that you're
thinking look things are expanding right
it's like taking a box of gas and making
the box bigger when you make a box of
gas bigger the maximum entropy does go
up because now you have more room in the
box okay
but the point is
you're fixing the size of the box
yourself it's not a closed system right
you are changing the size of the walls
in the box as an external uh control if
you like whereas the universe is a
closed system the universe is just the
universe so you don't say well i'm going
to fix the size of the universe or the
density of stuff and then calculate the
maximum entropy i mean you could do that
but who cares it's a mistake people do
it all the time but it's a mistake to
think of that as the maximum entropy
because the physical system
that you're looking at is not a bunch of
photons and atoms in a certain space
time it's the photons and the atoms and
the space time itself
so you can ask could it have been in a
higher entropy state and the answer is
yes just put everything in a black hole
or for that matter
don't put everything in a black hole but
just expand the universe
that's a physical change in the system
that is perfectly allowed and lets you
have many many more
ways you can arrange the things and
therefore much much higher entropy
indeed
sometimes people say that the highest
entropy state you can get is a black
hole but that's wrong the highest
entropy state you can get in a theory
with gravity is just empty space
if you wait long enough the universe
will expand everything goes away you'll
be nothing left with nothing but empty
space and you can show that is the
highest entropy state aidan chatwin
davies nine uh even aiden was a grad
student at caltech he and i wrote a
paper proving this result
under certain assumptions under a bunch
of assumptions but i think the
assumptions are are good and it's
actually fascinating so let me explain
there is a theorem
by bob wald one of my old friends at
university of chicago brilliant general
relativist
uh bob showed that if you live in a
universe with a cosmological constant
right with vacuum energy pushing things
apart and you just wait
eventually either the universe
re-collapses or that vacuum energy
pushes everything apart and it sort of
doesn't matter what the details were
originally it's much like when you make
a black hole all the hair
oscillates away in gravitational waves
and you say black holes have no hair so
bob wald's theorem says is that it's a
cosmic no hair theorem it says that it
doesn't matter what you started with
eventually you get to empty space with
nothing but a cosmological constant
for years this made me think of the
second law of thermodynamics or of the
process of equilibration right the ice
cube melts it doesn't matter whether you
started with a glass of cool water or uh
one ice cube or two ice cubes or
whatever eventually you get to a glass
of cool water right they all go to the
same place just like the universe goes
to the same place so there's a
equilibration
no hair connection and i thought we
should try to make that rigorous and so
aiden figured out a way to do it
and he and i wrote a paper showing that
if you have a
a system in curved space time with a
maximum possible entropy
that system goes to
empty space expanding exponentially like
it has a cosmological constant and we
didn't even use einstein's equation or
anything like that
so you can think of this
evolution of the universe in the
direction of
emptiness
as increasing entropy so that's a proof
that the highest entropy state you can
be in is completely empty space um i
think i've answered anyone's everyone's
questions reiner gluga said oh is
entropy just an epic phenomenon and
therefore maybe not applying to the
early universe
um
you have to be careful what you mean by
degrees of freedom you know um
the early universe may have been
dominated by inflation by an inflaton
field with no particles in it but again
just like for the expanding universe
that is one particular physical
configuration that could have been in a
lot of other physical configurations
including a whole bunch of gas and dust
or a bunch of black holes or empty space
all these are other possible physical
configurations of that early universe
it is not easy to have to write down a
once and for all formula
for what the entropy is in such a
situation but we know it's very very low
and we have pretty good formulas in
certain special cases like black holes
and like to sitter space and things like
that so it is absolutely okay
to apply entropy as a concept to the
early universe there are enough degrees
of freedom there
okay at this rate this is going to be an
eight hour uh ama so i better speed up
okay dan o'neill says
i learned a lot from your podcast with
david wallace oh it's another entropy
question but slightly different one
i learned a lot from your podcast with
david wallace on the arrow of time but
i'm still confused by how time's hour
relates to what we perceive to be the
flow of time
i don't see how boltzmann's
probabilistic interpretation of the
second law of thermodynamics explains
why we feel that time is something that
flows or that we move through
well yeah that's perfectly legit and be
confused about that these are ongoing
research problems
let me explain the basic reason why we
think that something like that is the
right answer
there
according to the laws of physics
according to our best current
understanding of the universe time isn't
something that flows that's not a
fundamental feature of time time's just
a label on where you are in the universe
when you are i should say in the
universe where you are in space time if
you like
um and there's not even any difference
between the physics of moving toward the
future and the physics and moving toward
the past at the fundamental level the
level of the fundamental laws of physics
the difference between the past and the
future comes exclusively
because entropy is increasing or more
generally because the early universe was
in a very very special state
and from that state the universe is
evolving and that's what gives time its
direction that's where times arrow comes
from okay
so if you believe that is the only
place the times arrow comes from as i do
then any impression we have the time is
flowing has to come from there there's
nowhere else for it to come to from
sorry
and indeed you can kind of see how that
happens because what you do is you
connect
the fact that entropy is increasing to
other well-known features of the arrow
of time like you remember the past and
not the future your causal impact flows
toward the future and not the past etc
it's these aspects of time that give us
the feeling that time flows as human
beings and if you haven't listened to it
i encourage you to listen to the podcast
episode with janae and ismail because we
talked about exactly this she's the
world's expert on this
um you're constantly carrying with you
in your brain
uh memory of what you were just doing
and also a prediction for what you're
about to be doing next um i talked a
little bit about this with david purple
also
um so
it's that comparison of where you are
now when you just were and where you
think you're going to be that gives you
this psychological feeling that you're
flowing through time
and
ultimately that's because entropy is
increasing that's where that distinction
comes from
anonymous says could you talk about any
proposed links between gravity and
electromagnetism um
i'm sorry anonymous that's a little bit
too vague for me to give a very explicit
answer to but i wanted to address a
little bit for two reasons or sort of in
two different ways
one way is if someone had the idea that
somehow magnetism
was either
part of gravity or the explanation for
gravity okay so that is an idea that
people have had and the idea is not
correct
they're similar there's relationships
between gravity and magnetism but
they're not the same
einstein tried very hard to unify
gravity and electromagnetism these days
we think that was a little bit misplaced
because he was trying to say let's
ignore the nuclear forces and you
probably can't do that
but gravity and electromagnetism as we
currently understand them are certainly
different but
analogous in some sense things one of
the reasons the biggest reason why
they're different at the practical level
is electromagnetism has both positive
and negative charges
whereas gravity only has positive
charges gravity only ever attracts one
particle only ever attracts another
particle never pushes it away
there's no there's no negative gravity
particles in the universe and that's
crucially crucially important for the
difference between gravity and
electromagnetism the other aspect of the
question is
um
in the world of electromagnetism there's
electro and there's magnetism so there's
one underlying thing going on but there
is sort of a manifestation of that thing
in the form of the electric field
there's a different manifestation of it
in the form of the magnetic field and
this was all unified by einstein
basically right in the special theory of
relativity uh the beginning of the
unification went back to maxwell but
really understanding them from the point
of view of relativity is the is the
ultimate way to go and so you could ask
is there a similar
decomposition in gravity is there sort
of electro gravity and magneto gravity
and the answer is yes
it's a much less relevant fact because
magnetism becomes important when charges
are moving fast right close to the speed
of light therefore gravido magnetism
would become important when gravitating
objects are moving close to the speed of
light but gravitating objects tend not
to do that i mean photons do it and
photons move into the speed of light but
they're so tiny that they don't make a
big gravitational field things that make
big gravitational fields tend to be
really heavy and slowly moving
so typically usually unless you really
care about details of black holes it is
the electrical
version of gravity that matters for what
you observe in astronomy in our everyday
lives
riverside says the economist magazine
just produced just pronounced in a long
article about the state of quantum
physics that your and brian swingle's
modeling of entropic gravity with the
use of quantum information theory is the
closest thing that may put string theory
to the rest
such journalistic simplifications aside
the lhc and fermilab muon experiments do
seem to retire supersymmetry as a viable
experimental outcome while quantum
entanglement becomes a more
experimentally promising area are we
looking at the possible way out of an
impasse
uh impasse sorry will the mathematical
apparatus of the string theory somehow
become scavenged and reused as part of
entropic gravity entanglement
information theory field um a lot going
on here also let me try to break things
down um
so yeah and there's a nice article in
the economist you need to subscribe to
the economist but that's okay uh i'm a
believer in subscribing to things and
supporting journalism they did a nice
article on
the state of quantum gravity and how
string theory is a little bit stalled
and some of us
brian swingle was mentioned are trying
to and i was mentioned uh trying to
build up quantum gravity from quantum
mechanics and quantum information theory
so let me say by the way it's not just
me and brian swingle like just it's even
when it's me it's certainly me and my
collaborators charles tau spiroz
mikalakis ashmit singh
aiden who i already mentioned and a
bunch of other people have been involved
in this project with me and then there
are other people like um steve giddings
tom banks who have been working on this
for a long time also so it there's a
there's a smaller number it's not like
the
tidal wave sweeping the world there's
nowhere nearly as many people working on
this as there are on more conventional
string theory but we exist okay
um
that's one thing to say
and i'm very optimistic about it you've
heard me say i'm optimistic about it so
but there's a long way to go we're not
close to a breakthrough as far as i can
tell
the second thing to say is i'm i'm
confused as to why you write lhc and
fermion muon experiments seem to retire
supersymmetry i think it's exactly the
opposite of that
the recent experiments seem to show
anomalies
in the behavior of muons their decays
and their coupling to other particles
which could be signatures of
supersymmetry like we don't know yet we
don't even know if those experiments are
going to turn out if those anomalies are
going to turn out to persist over time
but they certainly don't rule out
supersymmetry
third thing is
even if they did
even if they were not related to
supersymmetry even if we just don't find
supersymmetry at the electroweak scale
it's still absolutely possible that
superstring theory is right superstring
theory requires supersymmetry to make
contact with the physical world
but it doesn't require that signatures
of supersymmetry are accessible to us
experimentally they could be up at the
planck scale or they would be completely
un uh inaccessible now it's true that
for many many years people have focused
their attention
on versions of supersymmetry that are
experimentally accessible that's not
necessarily because those are the best
models it's because being experimentally
accessible is important and we care
about it we want to do the experiments
etc
so as i've said before
the fact that we haven't found
supersymmetry at the lhc or elsewhere
should lower your credence that
supersymmetry is true and therefore
lower your credence that string theory
is true but it might not lower it by a
lot that depends on what your priors are
and even some
difficult to calculate likelihood
functions
um okay finally um will the mathematical
apparatus of string theory be become
somehow scavenged
uh yeah looks look on one let me
emphasize string theory is not dead it
might still be correct but more
importantly if even if it were dead
we've learned a lot by doing string
theory you know all of the stuff
on um
ads cft and holography and all that
stuff grew out of string theorists not
to mention
string theory trying to understand uh
condensed matter systems or strongly
coupled nuclear systems or other things
like that so
the what we've learned from string
theory will continue to be useful down
the road
richard graf says you convinced me that
emergence oh i'm grouping a bunch of
questions together here emergence is the
key to understanding how the quantum
world manifests in the macro world we
experience but what is the state of
emergence study has it coalesced into
what could be called a science or math
of emergence
uh andrei mirabelli says it seems easy
to think about how rules about gliders
emerge from rules about grid occupation
that's a reference to
john conway's game of life uh the
cellular automaton that is very famous
and laws about liquidity emerge from
laws about molecules it is harder for me
to see how the very existence of
particles emerges from laws about the
probability amplitude wave for states or
particles it is still harder for me to
see how the
experience of awareness awareness
emerges from material laws can you
provide some guidance for how to more
specifically think about emergence in
ways that can make its meaning clearer
in these seemingly more powerful senses
john stout says i'm grouping four
questions together here so number three
is john stout says emergence can you
explain this to me in more detail
it is difficult to grasp how to label
one or another effect as emergent
basically it's a similar question to
what andre just said and then josh said
when you reason about immersion
phenomena are you merely using a
shortcut to reason about the underlying
structures or is there a sense in which
understanding at the level of phenomena
is different than merely being able to
reason about how the constituent parts
fit together like for example do humans
who understand concepts like center of
mass and democracy have a sort of
understanding which laplace's demon
could never have
so yeah this is um so there's a bunch of
things here about emergence and what it
is and where it's going so uh
i said this before i'm sure but let me
try to summarize how i think about this
idea of emergence you know it's not a
great word emergence let me put it that
way when i was first writing the big
picture and i was using emergence all
the time like on every page
many people especially philosophers but
also sociologists and others said oh my
god don't use that word it's too
overburdened with different meanings and
it means different things to different
people and it will just be confusing and
i thought i almost didn't
use it but
you know once the cat's out of a bag
it's very very difficult to invent new
nomenclature for things people use the
word emergence to talk about this stuff
here is why it can get confusing because
physicists think about emergence as
saying that there exists
well so both everyone who thinks about
emergence thinks that thinks about the
world in terms of levels okay and the
level metaphor is a little bit
misleading in its own right but let's
for right now go with it so there's sort
of microscopic levels where you talk
about particles and fields and forces
etc
very very tiny things coming together to
make bigger things and there are
macroscopic levels whether it's
chemistry biology humanity sociology
astronomy
what have you
and what the physicist will say is
the different levels might very well
speak different vocabularies use
different words right the vocabulary we
use to describe human psychology is very
different than the vocabulary of the
standard model of particle physics or
the core theory if you like
but the physicists would say they're
compatible
it's just that the higher level emergent
description
is
taking advantage of the existence of
patterns that simplify things that are
implicit in the lower level dynamics
um so in other words for that's why i
like to use the center of mass
of the earth as a special example
you don't need to know
all the positions and velocities of the
particles in the earth to predict its
motion around the sun you only need to
know the center of mass position and
velocity
but that's not
easy or obvious or necessary right
that's a special miraculous thing about
the laws of physics
you are throwing away almost all the
information and still making good
predictions because the information that
you're keeping the center of mass
position and velocity is really really
really specific and special
okay
so if you had thrown away random
information you'd be able to predict
nothing like let's say you threw away
all the positions and you kept only the
momentum of all the particles in the
earth right so you know the average
momentum of the earth you have no idea
where it is
so even though you're now keeping half
of the information
you make zero predictions about where
the earth is actually going to be and
that's the generic situation if you just
keep some fraction of the information
about the underlying system it does not
allow you to predict anything at all
roughly speaking so emergence in this
physicist sense
is a special wonderful extraordinarily
useful feature of nature of reality that
there exists these other ways of talking
about the world that are from the point
of view the microscopic theory woefully
deficient in information and yet capture
something real dan dennett called these
features real patterns that really exist
there
now there are also
other people
in philosophy and sociology etc
communities who think about it very much
the other way around they think that
they use emergence to mean explicitly
cases where there are behaviors in the
macroscopic level that cannot be
understood in terms of just the
microscopic level something that is
truly new
so you couldn't put the microscopic
theory on a computer
run it and get the right answer because
there's something truly new that's the
idea of strong emergence in some uh
classification schemes okay so i never
mean strong emergence i only mean weak
emergence so to get to andre's question
and to um
john's question um that's what i mean by
emergence
um
it's a little bit
the point is that well actually let me
let me get richard's question first
cause maybe this will help um there's a
lot we don't understand about emergence
richard is asking you know what is the
state of the study of emergence there's
a lot we don't understand
and the basic reason why there's a lot
we don't understand is because if what
you want to understand is particle
physics
the best way to make progress is to
study particle physics if what you want
to understand is biology the best way to
make progress is to study biology and if
you want to understand psychology the
best way to make progress is to study
psychology so clearly all of these
different levels have to be compatible
with each other but studying the ways in
which they're compatible
is very
much less common than just studying the
levels in and of themselves and because
we can just look out the window and see
human beings and big macroscopic
structures
we take for granted
that they must be explicable in terms of
atoms and so forth without ever actually
doing the work to say you know what is
the general theory of when is there an
emergent description when is a
macroscopic theory compatible with
microscopic theory and all that stuff
so i would say that there's a lot of
work to be done in the theory of
emergence we'll be talking about it in
upcoming podcasts i think it's important
and interesting um
but there are people studying it right
that's i guess that's the point um like
i said at the beginning this is part of
why i'm here
in uh in harvard ned hall who is another
mindscape guest uh and sort of my host
here in the philosophy department you
know jokingly said over email yeah like
while you're here in the fall let's
let's figure out emergence once and for
all so we're gonna try to do that i'll
let you know if that happens uh but okay
but the point is so that's the state of
emergence namely it's it's i think it's
young and still underdeveloped um
but this fact that we can cheat by
seeing the higher levels immediately
or in sort of just using our eyes rather
than always starting with the lower
level and deriving the higher level uh
means on the one hand we can talk about
different levels without understanding
emergence very well but also it mean it
makes the phenomenon of emergence
sometimes hard to understand
because
there's part of us especially if we know
about examples like fluid mechanics
right like fluid mechanics emerges from
atoms and molecules
there
we can derive fluid mechanics from atoms
and molecules you can literally go from
the microscopic theory to the
macroscopic one or the
center of mass motion of the earth you
can derive that isaac newton did it
um
whereas so so that gives you the
impression that what emergence is about
or what the study or use of emergence is
about should be somehow deriving
the higher levels from the lower levels
and that might be arbitrarily hard you
know the levels need to be consistent
but it might be
effectively impossible to derive them
that doesn't mean that it couldn't be
done but we human beings can't do it or
something like that and as a result the
emergent levels can involve concepts and
vocabularies that are entirely different
from the concepts and vocabularies at
lower levels that's even a little bit
true even for liquids right for fluid
mechanics i mean we we talk about
temperature and pressure and density
when we talk about fluids none of those
rules is there none of those words uh is
there at the level of atoms individual
atoms and molecules and so we don't make
a big fuss about it because we're so
used to it but it's exactly the same
for uh classical particles emerging out
of quantum mechanics or for humans and
their psychological properties emerging
out of biology and ultimately from
physics it don't think about a direct
route from the microscopic theory to the
macroscopic theory think about both
theories existing
and as a research program find the
connections between them that's a better
way of thinking about how emergence
actually works
finally josh asks a very good question
you know
would does emergence give us human
beings some insight and understanding
that laplace's demon wouldn't have after
all laplace's demon knows where all the
particles are all their positions all
their velocities and can predict where
they're going to be in the future uh so
is there some sense in which laplace's
demon knows everything but only at the
microscopic level you know i don't want
to speak for laplace's team and i don't
know what laplace's demon knows and
doesn't know um but i know what you mean
um
the reason why i said i want to speak
for the boss's demon is i don't think
that the thought experiment is perfectly
well defined like no one has ever agreed
on exactly what
you know capacities and abilities the
boss's demon has
so i could easily imagine laplace's
demon
just knowing the microscopic laws right
just knowing the most comprehensive
fundamental level of reality and not
realizing that there were these
simplifications i mean after all if you
have the exact solution in your head who
cares about the simplifications right
but i can also imagine a version of
laplace's demon that understood not just
the microscopic level but every possible
level
of the emergent descriptions of reality
so i don't know you know that i think
that those are different versions of
applause as a demon but none is uh the
right one or the wrong one
okay
spooly orange says if a particle is a
wave in a quantum field does it also
exert a force on the surrounding field
towards the center of the wave for
example a standing wave on a string held
between two clamps exerts a force on the
clamps toward the center of the wave um
yes it can
they can right in fact there's a very
famous phenomenon called the casimir
effect which is exactly this
um you don't even need particles you can
just have waves the quantum fields in
the vacuum
and what you say is that if you imagine
two parallel plates that are perfectly
conducting right so what that means is
if the if the plate conducts electricity
perfectly the superconductor
then electric and magnetic fields cannot
penetrate electric fields cannot
penetrate inside so it cuts off the
different wave modes that you can have
in the space in between the two plates
and it turns out that the existence of
some modes of the quantum fields but not
others in between the plates
exerts a force on them i don't want to
say it pulls because sometimes it pushes
it depends on whether the fields or
bosons or fermions but this is something
which you can actually test
experimentally and then there are
philosophical arguments about whether
it's really the vacuum modes or whatever
but i think the most straightforward way
of thinking about it is exactly that so
in that sense yes
douglas albrecht says would you mind
providing an explanation of what energy
is especially as it relates to the
quantum is it mass is it field frequency
is it momentum in its essence what is
energy
uh so it's none of those things
energy i think the right way to think
about energy it doesn't even matter
quantum versus classical energy is a
property
i think it's a mistake to start thinking
about energy as a thing and i i know why
people would think about it as a thing
because it's conserved so you know if
you have a bunch of water and a bunch of
pots and pans the amount of water is
conserved as you pour the water from one
pan to another right and so you think of
the water as a thing and it's conserved
and since energy is conserved it can be
transferred from one thing to another
it's kind of tempting to think of it as
a substance in some sense but it's not
what's the substance are the stuff in
substances or the stuff in the universe
particles and things like that right so
we talk about the energy of a particle
particles can have kinetic energy and
potential energy it's etc right so is a
property of a particle or a field or a
bunch of particles and what property is
it you know it's the property that is
conserved
because the laws of physics are
invariant under time translations this
was the uh this is nerder's theorem emmy
nerder was the mathematician who proved
that when
there is a symmetry of nature there's an
associated conservation law and the laws
of physics have a symmetry namely
they're the same laws at every moment in
time there's a no
force outside the universe twiddling a
knob changing the value of the fine
structure constant or the mass of the
electron or anything like that um these
are constants of nature at least within
our observable universe and so because
of that
symmetry because of time translation and
variance there is a conserved quantity
and it's the energy that's what it is
and now if that's too abstract for you
then all you have to do is say well give
me a physical system that you define
very carefully and i can figure out what
the energy is if it's a ball rolling
down a hill there's a kinetic energy and
a potential energy etc that's the
formula i would use to calculate that
property that the ball has and that is
what energy is
jeffrey siegel says i seem to recall in
a previous ama that you mentioned that
most of the expansion of the universe is
occurring between galaxies with dark
matter appearing mainly between galaxies
i got the impression this is not simply
because galaxies are flying off in many
directions but rather that space is
indeed expanding between the galaxies if
that is correct is there a theoretical
reason for space to be selectively
expanding between galaxies so
i want to get rid of the phrase dark
matter that somehow appeared in the
middle of that uh question that has
nothing to do with dark matter there's
more dark matter in the galaxies than in
between the galaxies there's some dark
matter in between galaxies but it
collapses and concentrates just like
ordinary matter does in galaxies and
clusters of galaxies um is there a
reason for space to be expanding between
the galaxies yes but it's kind of the
other way around it's not that space
expands between the galaxies it's that
inside galaxies space isn't expanding
anymore okay in the early universe where
there were no galaxies everything was
more or less smoothly distributed
everything was expanding space was just
expanding but there were regions where
there's a little bit more matter than
elsewhere a little bit more gravity and
that gravity pulled things together and
once the matter sort of stops moving
apart and the overall local
gravitational pull starts pulling them
together
at that point it is no longer meaningful
to say that the expansion of the
universe is having any effect whatsoever
inside that region of space so i think
the better way of thinking of it is
space is expanding everywhere except
where there is a galaxy or some other
concentration of matter
now for something completely different
we have i'm going to group two questions
together about relationship advice
relationship advice something again that
i'm not an expert on but do have
experience with so why not
casey mahone asks how can you tell
whether a relationship is worth fighting
for
and michelle to group together says what
is your advice for dealing with people
who are condescending and self-important
i don't by grouping these together mean
to imply that casey's relationship is
with someone who is condescending and
self-important but there are certain
commonalities between these two
questions and
you know again i'm not
in any sense uh qualified to give
empirically evidence-based answers to
these questions but my own personal
impression is
that if i've learned anything about
people
in the context of relationships is that
people don't change that much that
quickly i do think people can change
people certainly do change people when
they're 50 years old or not the same as
when they were 20 years when they were
five it's just obvious that people
change but there are certain
commonalities
and
major changes the kinds of which would
have a large impact on a close personal
relationship are rare and therefore the
older i get the more my philosophy of
relationships is just have relationships
with good people
from the start rather than having
relationships with not good people and
trying to fix them so the relevance of
this uh observation to casey's question
how do you tell whether a relationship
is worth fighting for i mean
part of me wants to say almost never
it depends on exactly what kind of
situation you're in but you know and
what you mean by fighting for the
relationship do you mean someone wants
to leave you
and you're gonna fight to keep them
you're gonna sort of try to convince
them that it's right uh almost never
would i try to do that if they're still
maybe interested and just not sure then
by all means talk it out you know try to
figure out what's going on how you can
be better but if they want to leave you
know let them leave
do something else get another person
find someone who is a better fit with
you from the start i mean if you there's
it's not that people are stuck and can
never change and therefore relationships
can never change
but
but rather than
fighting for the relationship or trying
to change the other person it seems to
be me to be much more fruitful to try to
look inside yourself
and ask what is it about you that is not
making this work what is it that you can
improve changing yourself is really
really hard but it's much easier easier
than changing other people
um now on the other hand if there are
two people who are very much want to be
in a relationship but there is some
particular aspect of it that is not
working right so it's not that you're
fighting the person who wants to leave
you both want to stay but there's
something that's not working that's
worth trying to do
try to figure out are there parameters
that you have where you can both alter
your behaviors in ways that fixes things
um but often there are just
incompatibilities and you know i've
often seen with people i know
what they look for in a person
is not what they really need in a person
right uh they're looking when they're
out there on the market they have a
checklist and they want to go through
the checklist but then when they're in
the relationship what they actually want
to need is something very very different
so you have to be open to the
possibility that there were sparks
flying there at the beginning and yet
now it is not worth rekindling those
sparks and i hate to be a downer about
this
um
but you know there's a lot of people out
there and when we're talking about
romantic kinds of relationships
uh i think that the
usefulness of your time is much better
spent finding the right person for you
rather than trying to fit somebody else
into a situation that doesn't quite um
work for them someone else will be right
for them hopefully and then michelle's
question you know the reason why this is
related is not because the questions are
related but because the answers are
related michelle's question was how do
you deal with people who are
condescending and self-important
the answer is to any extent possible you
don't
don't try to fix them don't try to offer
witty one-liners that will you know
bring them down the ground don't try to
explain why this is not good way to be
unless you know they're open to that you
know some people are open some people
make mistakes sure and are willing to
fix them but other people like being
condescending and self-important that's
kind of their shtick that's kind of who
they are
and i would say just don't hang with
those people to any extent possible
sometimes it's not possible right it's
your boss or it's your student for that
matter right um it's someone you have a
relationship with for some external
reason that you can't get rid of so
in that case you know i i think that
condescension and self-importance are
kinds of flaws that are not closely
related to any real virtues right other
than being awesome like if the person is
awesome and that's why they're
self-important because they really are
important then you know what can i say
um but more often
um it's not like you know
someone is a workaholic right where
workaholism has positive aspects and
negative aspects
even being lazy you can in some sense
have positive aspects or negative
aspects the flip side of being a
workaholic um
but being condescending and
self-important is just bad
so
typically people who are really
characterized by those
personality traits aren't going to
change them that's just who they are
and so
if you can't minimize your dealings with
them in contact with them i would try to
minimize your responses to them just let
it roll off your back to the extent that
you can you know um twitter is a great
uh training ground for this if you can
ignore people who are saying dumb things
on twitter and condescending and
self-important things for example then
you could ignore them anywhere because
your your real life
barriers to trying to strike back
uh are much greater than they are on the
internet for whatever reason i don't
know so i don't think i don't know
whether michelle or casey whether that
my advice in either one of those cases
is very actionable and and helpful to
you but it's my attitude you know again
it's like as i get older as i've seen
things i've lived my life life's too
short man it's too short to be with the
wrong people in the wrong situations um
two we spend far far too much time
trying to fix a bad situation rather
than trying to find a good situation
that's a very over-generalized statement
but sticking to it
antoine chopin says
congratulations on your new role at
santa fe institute you told us your
research focus would be on complex
systems could you give us a glimpse on
what it is
what it is and how it relates or not
with what you've studied so far so i
should have maybe i could have grouped
this with the emergence question
actually because that's the basic
question um you know complex systems is
itself a pretty broad field if you go to
santa fe one of the great things about
the institute is
they'll be archaeologists they'll be
economists they'll be physicists they'll
be computer scientists they'll be
philosophers
it's an enormous range of traditional
disciplines that have something to do
with complexity in some way and so
likewise you know the field of complex
systems is itself very very big
um so my specific kinds of interests
within complex systems
uh are the sort of general
structural questions the the
quasi-philosophical questions so just
like within physics i'm much more
interested in general principles than in
specific physical systems you know this
or that particle or planet or material
or whatever within complex systems i'm
much less interested in this or that
complex systems and in rules by which we
can somehow find commonalities between
very very different kinds of complex
systems and in particular i would say
that
the you know to specify it a bit more my
current research interest is in relating
the lowest most fundamental level
of physics which is where i've spent
most my life studying two levels above
so entropy is a huge role in that right
the arrow of time is a huge role in that
but
the very idea of emergence is exactly
this idea right how you can relate
different levels to each other are there
causal relations between them are there
supervision or entailment relations
between them
in what situations in what what are the
criteria by which you say that
immersions can happen does it happen the
same time all the way um
when you go from
small numbers of particles to large
numbers of particles
sometimes
there are emerging phenomena sometimes
there are not sometimes those phenomena
are complex and sometimes they're not
you know like a bucket of water has a
lot of particles in it but it's not
complex all by itself so what's the
difference what are the criteria you
need to say that something is complex
and hell will operate and there once you
have those things can you use them to
say things like how are economies
similar to the nervous system or to the
internet or something like that that's
the kind of thing at the very broadest
scale that i would be interested in
okay so i'm going to group together
there's a whole bunch of questions on
decoherence maybe this is just random
quantum fluctuation or maybe it's
because of the david wallace podcast but
a bunch of questions so joseph dundee
says what is the relationship between
decoherence and measurement they seem
almost like the same thing to me
marco tausser says as i understand it
decoherence can be thought of as due to
the leaking of information from a system
to its environment this is why
schrodinger's sleepy wakey cat is
already decoy here long before we open
the box the information about the cat
leaks through the walls of the box
within a microsecond of when the
superposition is first established my
question is can there conceivably be
anything that we can make the box out of
so that the information doesn't leak out
does nature allow decoherence shields
bill warner says can you help me
understand decoherence
that's a very basic question i can't
picture a diagram for it either
copenhagen or many worlds benjamin
barbrell says my question is about the
measurement problem in quantum mechanics
this problem arises from trying to find
the boundary between classical and
quantum behaviors i understand that
coherence essentially solves this
problem my right to put it like this
how complete is our understanding of
decoherence is it still the object of
theoretical or experimental research so
there's a couple things going on here as
usual
as a phenomenon decoherence is pretty
well understood it is uh i mean there
are details about when it happens how it
happens how you can avoid it how quickly
it happens those are all good technical
questions but the idea is pretty solid
namely
uh you often very very very often find
yourself in quantum mechanics in a
situation where you have a system of
interest cat an atom spin whatever
and you have an environment you have the
whole rest of the world and of course
even classical physics you had an
environment but the difference is in
classical physics
you could go to a regime where the
environment didn't matter where you did
in fact shield it off as marco suggests
um you know if i'm standing here and i'm
being bombarded by photons if you turn
off the lights in the room and i'm not
being bombarded by photons i don't
change that much in any particular way
whereas in quantum mechanics the
environment becomes entangled with you
very quickly so you just you can't uh
not include the environment and that
process of becoming entangled with the
environment is what decoherence is so
you basically say i have the system i
have literally everything else in the
universe and i say does the system stay
unentangled with everything else or does
it become entangled if it becomes
entangled that's decoherence if it does
not become entangled it's coherent
that's the maintenance of quantum
coherence so
bill you want a picture of it
a diagram you know i'm not sure what
how to do that you know usually this
might be a bit too hardcore on my part
but usually
for to these kinds of questions i say
you know
too bad there's no there's no diagram
for this not everything can be
visualized especially in quantum
mechanics where things are uh many many
dimensional right far more numbers of
dimensions than we can plot on a piece
of paper
but you want a picture i mean the
picture is just this a picture of
schroedinger's cat awake
entangled with an environment that is
interacting with it and schrodinger's
cat asleep entangled with an environment
that is interacting with it that's
that's basically what you should picture
in your mind
what is the relationship of this to
measurement actually let me first um
answer the other questions uh marco says
can you shield decoherence well yes and
no um you can't shield d coherence for a
macroscopic system in the real world
the cat in the box is a system but the
photons and air molecules
in the box count as the environment it's
not only the environment outside the box
in fact usually when i say
that the coherence happens long before
you open the box i'm thinking about the
parts of the environment inside the box
okay that are going on
having said that
if you wanted to be more general about
it and just ask the question can you
shield one kind of system from becoming
entangled with another yes i mean this
is the job of quantum computer builders
because to do a quantum computation you
need multiple qubits which entangle with
each other but not with the rest of the
world you want to shield them from
decoherence that's exactly what you want
to do so you make everything very very
cold you know it's it's harder than you
think because you can say turn off the
light so there's no photons
but at room temperature everything
around you is glowing if you put on your
infrared goggles you'd see there's
actually lots of photons in the room
there are radio waves and things like
that also so it's harder to shield out
photons than you would think which is
why it's harder to shield that shield
out decoherence than you would think
the other two questions is about the
relationship between
decoherence and measurement
the reason why the relationship is fuzzy
is because the word measurement is fuzzy
the word decoherence is not fuzzy we
know what decoherence is but measurement
is something where we say we know it
when we see it like i've measured
something
but what is actually physically
happening during the active measurement
will be different depending on your
favorite interpretation of quantum
mechanics so because your favorite
interpretation is obviously the effort
interpretation there's a very very close
relationship between decoherence and
measurement but in other interpretations
it might not be so
if there were no other interpretations
of quantum mechanics and ever were just
accepted as correct then there would be
a very close relationship basically
what we think of as human measurement is
just one of one subset of the larger
numbers of things that can happen where
a system becomes decoherent and you
might as well call all of them
measurements it's different than
interactions i think maybe someone else
asked about the relationship between
measurement and interaction you can
interact something without becoming
entangled with it if i have a
spin that is in a superposition of spin
up and spin down and i just pick it up
and move it but i don't measure the spin
i have i have interacted with it but
i've not become entangled with it so
it's not a measurement it's not
uh decoherence going on because the
entanglement didn't happen
uh rebecca lashwa says are all physical
phenomena computable
most real numbers are not computable and
only computable countable subset of them
is does this mean that space time is
much smaller than r4 r4 is the
four-dimensional smooth uh euclidean
space
do you think the universe is necessarily
computable i.e that is incoherent to
imagine existing within a universe that
can't be computed by some algorithm
um i think that the issue with this
question is we haven't
quite defined what we mean by computable
in the following sense
obviously there are definitions of what
we mean by computable and when you say
the phrase most real numbers are not
computable
that refers to a specific definition of
what computable means namely ways to
calculate numbers
and as you say
most real numbers are not computable
there's no algorithm you can write down
that would specify
that particular number this is it's a
kind of counterintuitive thing to those
people who have not studied analysis or
topology but you know the real line has
a lot of numbers in it let's put it that
way more than you think
um
and so
but that's
doesn't that notion of computability
doesn't immediately translate to
physical phenomena right like what do
you mean by all physical phenomena
computable like here's a physical
phenomenon when i uh let go of the
coffee cup in front of me it lands on
the table and doesn't fall through
what does it mean to say that's
computable i mean it's predictable
but do i need to specify the literally
exact location of the coffee cup do i
need to you know be laplace's demon
somehow i don't know what exactly what
that means
it seems as we've already talked about
to be a feature of our physical universe
that it obeys rules right it obeys the
laws of physics so in that sense it's
computable um
but the thing that is computing it is
the world so the world itself can be
thought of in some sense as a computer
going from one moment of time to the
next
um
but
you know it it does uncomputable things
in some sense the court if if the laws
of physics were just newton's laws of
classical mechanics space is is a
continuum um that is part of the
definition and whether that's physically
right i have no idea but i i can
certainly i don't have any obstacles to
imagining things like that being right
and the fact that i can't write a
computer algorithm
uh for every single possible real number
doesn't get in the way of doing that as
far as i can tell so i'm not sure if
that's a satisfying answer but that's
how i think about uh these questions
just need to be a little bit more
careful what you mean by computable
brandon lewis says what topics or
concepts in mathematics beyond calculus
do you find useful in theoretical
physics well many i mean many many many
you know you can buy fairly thick
textbooks called you know mathematical
methods for physics or for physical
sciences or something like that and
these books usually
talk about ideas past simple calculus
you'll take a class in calculus where
you learn derivatives and integrals
the mathematical methods courses will
then do vector calculus complex numbers
so
complex calculus also but then also
maybe linear algebra so matrices and
vectors um a lot of differential
equations and solutions to differential
equations which in some sense is part of
calculus but so much material there you
need another course to talk about it
and then a tremendous amount on
transforms of functions right fourier
transforms laplace transforms
turning
data in one space like position space
into data in another space like momentum
space or frequency space and things like
that so the grab bag of different
techniques
and then even beyond that you'll find
other books for more advanced students
called things like
geometry and topology for physicists and
then you learn something about rimani
and geometry and homotopy and homology
and
uh fiber bundles and things like that so
there are a lot of concepts in in math
that go
that are very useful in theoretical
physics it depends of course on what
kind of theoretical physics you want i
didn't even mention statistics but
that's just taken uh for granted
vincent ohm says will we ever be able to
understand the nature of consciousness
do you think what is the likely road
toward this understanding
um i think so i think we will i mean why
not like i i would when whenever someone
says we'll be able to understand the
nature of x i'm saying yeah sure why not
i mean maybe
now there are plenty of things that we
haven't yet understood and
there's a temptation to say well we have
understood yet therefore maybe it's not
possible to understand but you know you
could have said that a hundred years ago
about a million things that we do
understand now right so that's not a
very good argument
consciousness is one of the hardest
things to try to understand because it's
an emerging phenomena from one of the
most complex systems that we know about
you know the human brain and body
um so the fact that we don't understand
it yet
is the least surprising thing in the
world
what is a likely road toward this
understanding you know doing
neuroscience mostly some combination of
neuroscience and philosophy and
psychology but
you know i can't be more specific than
that because
number one i'm not a neuroscientist but
number two it's in the nature of science
to not know exactly what steps you
should take to get to the answer you're
looking for you just got to take steps
and try things and guess and see
what works
brandon lewis says
the phrase shut up and calculate comes
from comes up from time to time in
discussions related to theoretical
physics what sort of calculations are
usually being alluded to when this
phrase is invoked so this phrase was
invented by david murman who was a
physicist at cornell uh when he was
trying to characterize a certain
attitude that some people have not him
but some other people have toward
quantum mechanics you know some people
like me and like david merman really
want to understand the foundations of
quantum mechanics in a deep way
sometimes we even end up talking to
philosophers about it other people say
look we can use quantum mechanics just
fine we can predict the lifetime of the
neutron or the scattering rate of
something or the temperature high
temperature superconductivity phase
transition or something like that using
the rules of quantum mechanics and to do
that you need to do a calculation right
there's some integral you calculate the
amplitude of some possibility you square
that amplitude to get the probability
right that's what you calculate in
quantum mechanics those are the kinds of
calculations that are being talked about
so it would depend on the specific
system you're studying but it's just
typical physics calculations
sid huff says in a previous podcast you
briefly briefly mentioned the book quiet
by susan kane
about introversion and the challenge is
often faced by introverts so are you an
introvert and if so how do you think
this trait has affected your
professional career research teaching
etc so i think i am to be i'll be very
uh
uh to be fair to be honest two things
number one i haven't read susan kane's
book uh i've read a little bit of it
never like you know excerpts and heard
people talk about it so i'm familiar
with the basic idea but i haven't read
it and as a book writer myself i know
better than to mischaracterize what is
in other people's books
and secondly second caveat is
there's
research beyond what she wrote about in
the field of introversion and
extroversion and controversies about
that research and i'm not familiar with
that either
so rather than trying to be
too careful about the definition of
introvert
the one insight that a lot of people
really uh appreciated from that
discussion and i don't even know it was
original to her or she was quoting
somebody else but the idea that rather
than thinking of introverts as shy
people
or anti-social people you can think of
introversions as people who uh
it costs energy for them to interact
with others whereas extroverts actually
gain energy you know if they're
interacting with others you know they
get excited and it juices them up and if
they're left by themselves they kind of
sort of get antsy and uncomfortable
whereas introverts need to recharge
they need to be alone and have their
alone time and then
in the right circumstances they can go
out and interact with other people
i'm not sure if that's now the
accepted definition of introversion but
that's that's the uh
takeaway that i had from the discussion
around that book and by that definition
i'm absolutely an introvert you know i
absolutely need to be
uh
alone to recharge i'm not someone who
like so after i give a talk if i give a
public talk or whatever
i would really just like to go back to
my hotel room or whatever it is and have
some me time i'm not out there to party
afterward i'm exhausted usually
afterward it's i can do it i can do
small talk at parties i can uh talk
pleasantly to people i don't know
i can give lectures i can talk on tv i
can have a podcast i can do all those
things but it wears me out right so i
don't know if that counts as being an
introvert then yes i am uh introverted
in that sense uh how's it affected my
professional career i'm surrounded by
fellow introverts so it hasn't affected
it that much at all you know
there are people who
within academia or within physics or
within science uh take more and less
pleasure out of teaching and outreach
and giving talks and things like that um
and i like giving talks a lot i mean i
have a podcast come on it's pretty
obvious that i like interacting with
other people a lot
um
but i i didn't start out being any good
at it i wasn't you know a natural or
anything like that i was terrible at it
when i first started uh many many years
ago and i have worked to get better at
it and there's a lot of people in
academia who just don't bother to work
to get better at it so they remain not
very good for their whole lives so i
think a lot of people in academia are
natural introverts but um some of them
have gotten very very good interacting
with large groups of people or maybe
even small groups of people
moshe fader says
this goes back to an editorial
conference i had with a new author over
a decade ago we were talking about
future projects and he described a
science fantasy novel he done a little
work on it involved two inhabited
planets or maybe a planet in his large
moon that powerful sorcery had brought
gently together until they nearly
touched just a few miles apart my
question for you is what would happen if
the magic failed or was turned off and
normal physics restored
obviously the two bodies would
immediately close the small distance
between them but then what
so um
two pieces of bad news for you one is
they would not immediately close the
small distance between them it depends
on how they're moving right if the two
bodies are revolving around each other
in a common orbit around their center of
mass then you know in some idealization
where we forget about tides and friction
and things like that they would if they
were doing it at the right speed they
would stay exactly at that distance
between them just like the earth and the
moon stayed roughly the same distance
not exactly because the moon uh and the
earth both rotate as well as revolving
around each other and there are tidal
friction forces that actually gradually
pull them apart so
if the two planets were not tidally
locked with each other then they would
probably gradually uh drift apart
actually of course if they were not
revolving around each other if they were
not moving they would just smash into
each other and everything would uh
everyone would die i guess if they were
living on the planets that would be bad
the other piece of bad news is that the
novel has already been written
it's called roche world by robert
forward you know robert forward one of
my favorite science fiction authors not
because
he's a great writer he was not a great
stylist let's put it that way um but he
he was super duper imaginative i think a
professional physicist or or engineer or
something like that so he wrote
um dragon's egg which about life on a
neutron star and his other one of his
other novels called roche world or
alternative title the flight of the
dragonfly was literally about two
planets that were so close together
that uh they shared an atmosphere and
even uh oceans and things like that so
that has been explored and there's no
magic involved it was purely science
fiction if you want to check that out
this johnson says could you play devil's
advocate and explain why interpretations
other than the already an interpretation
exist
well there's two aspects here one is you
know the psychological aspects of people
just not liking the effort
interpretation okay so that might mean
they don't like the idea that there are
a lot of other worlds or they don't like
that the existence of these other worlds
is unobservable to them
or something like that it just rubs them
the wrong way you know i think those are
real you know it's very far from our
experience and
it's not even completely irrational to
say
that a scientific theory
that claims that the real nature of
reality is very very different in its
fundamental essence
then our everyday experience should be
treated skeptically right i mean i think
that it's okay to start your scientific
theorizing close to the phenomena that
you observe and i think there's good
reasons to in the case of quantum
mechanics go far beyond them but it's
okay
to start there and to be skeptical of
ones that go far beyond it but that's a
you know kind of more like i said
psychological uh worry there are also
good physics worries and i think that
there are two very good physics worries
about the everett interpretation one is
the probability question
in ordinary quantum mechanics certain
things happen with certain probabilities
in everett everything that can happen
everything for which you would
ordinarily assign a non-zero probability
actually does happen in some branch of
the wave function and so how do you
recover the physical information the
data the experience that we have of the
world
that if we measure spins over and over
and over again we get a certain fraction
of them being spin up in a certain
fraction being spin down that we can
predict very accurately right now i
think there's an answer to these
questions in fact i think there's more
than one good answer to that question uh
famously david deutsch and david wallace
used decision theory to derive
proof that you get the usual uh
predictions uh chip siebens and i uh
developed another idea based on previous
suggestions by lev weidman and others um
that use self-locating uncertainty so i
think it's an answerable question
but i get it if you're not completely
convinced it's it's tricky and it
involves philosophy as well as physics
and the other question which i think has
gotten even less attention which is what
i'm mostly thinking about these days is
the what we call the structure
question
every other interpretation of quantum
mechanics has a wave function the
schrodinger equation and extra stuff
okay
that extra stuff might be other hidden
variables or extra rules about how wave
functions spontaneously collapse or
something right some notion of what is
observable and what is not observable
for example whereas in the purest
versions of everybody in quantum
mechanics you just have wave functions
and the schrodinger equation you don't
have any extra stuff
so the journey from the pristine purity
and austerity of everybody in quantum
mechanics to the messy specificity of
the world is very long and potentially
fraught with peril
and not a lot of work has been put into
deriving the real world
from the bare bones version of
epheredian quantum mechanics so i'm
trying if you if you are a little bit
happy with some equations you can check
out my fairly recent paper called um
reality as a vector in hilbert space
there was a previous paper with ash meat
saying along the same lines called mad
dog of a readianism but the point for
your question is
these are perfectly good questions like
it's not at all obvious that this idea
of taking just a wave function and the
schrodinger equation and deriving the
world from it will work
we're doing it i'm pretty optimistic it
will work i would put good odds on it
but it's not obvious or set in stone as
long as that is true it's good that
other interpretations exist you know i
if i were the boss of reality and
science i would put less emphasis on the
other interpretations but i'm glad that
they exist and other people are working
on them richard riley says
i'd still like to know just how
electrons and protons fuse together to
create neutrons during the process of
neutron star formation does an electron
fuse with an up quark in a proton and
turn into a down quark and the resulting
neutron is the mass of the neutron in
general equal to the sum of the masses
of the proton plus however many
electrons it would need etc so i mean
basically yes
uh remember
uh an up quark sorry a proton is two up
quarks and a down the up quarks have
charged plus two thirds and the down
quarks have charged minus one third the
neutron is one up quark and two downs so
when you convert
let's do the more familiar one neutrons
decay
right so a neutron decaying is basically
the neutron turning into a proton and an
electron and an anti-neutrino
it needs to be an anti-neutrino to
conserve
a lepton number and all those things but
it's there and so
that's basically one of the down quarks
in the neutron converting into
an up quark plus an electron plus an
anti-neutrino you can draw a little
fineman diagrams to watch it happen um
i've i've drawn those finding diagrams
in many places including the biggest
ideas in the universe uh videos if you
if you want to check those out
um
so
the proton converting into a neutron is
basically the same thing in reverse you
go proton plus electron goes to neutron
plus neutrino
so
really that electron is glomming onto
one of the up quarks in the proton
converting it into a down quark and
spitting off a neutrino and that's why
when you make a supernova there's a lot
of neutrinos that come out we've even
detected some of them like in supernova
1987a
the the mass neutron is not equal to the
masses of the proton plus however many
electrons it needs because there's other
things going on for one thing the proton
the electron are not necessarily in the
same center of mass you know the mass of
an electron plus a proton is less than
the mass of a neutron so you need more
energy than that especially because
you're also spitting out a neutrino so
it's a complicated thing but don't worry
we have figured it all out you can you
can figure it out yourself uh it's
actually not that hard to do what we
call the kinematics of those reactions
neil glue says the three spatial
dimensions of the universe we live in
could go on forever in all directions or
they could wrap around in one two or
three dimensions
if they did wrap around in one or more
with a circumference less than the size
of the observable universe we might be
able to observe that do you know of any
astronomy or cosmology work considering
that possibility particularly
experiments to provide positive or
negative evidence for whether the
observable universe wraps around uh yeah
absolutely there's very
i'm not sure if active is the right word
but they were active research programs
to look for evidence of a finite
universe in the cosmic microwave
background
if the universe is finite in size but
you know wraps around on itself like a
taurus or something more complicated
than it could be that different parts of
the microwave background we look at are
actually the same physical location in
space
just looked at in different directions
so you can and you do
look at that and people have looked at
it and put very very strong constraints
on that possibility uh in fact janet
levin who was a previous mindscape guest
wrote a whole book about it she was one
of the experts in this field so her
first book was called how the universe
got its spots because in these
topologically non-trivial universes you
could get spots on the cosmic microwave
background so she talks about what that
would be and how you would go look for
it it's a very good book if you want to
check it out
matt faw asks a priority question
remember i don't know if you've had
priority questions yet today but uh
priority questions are the ones that i
promise to answer
but every human being is only allowed
one priority question per their life
span
in each branch of the wave function of
the universe
as i understand it space begins to
expand at t equals zero uniformly
everywhere therefore it seems like every
particle of matter or dark matter would
from t equals zero effectively move away
from every other particle in the
universe as space expands between them
the gravitational attraction between
every particle in the universe should
also get weaker
if expansion beat gravity at the very
first moment it seems like expansion
would always beat gravity because
gravity would just keep getting weaker
the further things got from each other
it seems as if expansion should lead to
a universe without structure just a fine
mist of verified particles so there's
two things
going on here one is i want to be a
little bit more specific about
what is happening at t equals zero
specifically you shouldn't say anything
about what happens at t equals zero t
equals zero by which i presume you mean
the singularity in the big bang models
of cosmology
is a singularity by singularity we mean
physical quantities become infinitely
big and therefore your theoretical
description of them is wrong
somehow we don't know what happens at t
equals zero so
if you wrap your brain into knots trying
to understand not just the very very
early universe but literally t equals
zero
you're going to come across paradoxes
because many of the things you're trying
to attach meaning to
are of the form zero times infinity or
zero divided by zero or something like
that including
the space between particles and and or
the size of the universe or things like
that these things are just not defined
at the big bang
one tiny moment after the big bang ten
to the minus some seconds then you can
talk about the whole universe and it
might already be infinitely big then and
there's some finite number of particles
per cubic centimeter etc okay that's one
thing but the other thing is more
straightforward you know you're saying
if expansion beats gravity the very
first moment it seems like expansion
would always beat gravity well no
because you know there's equations here
and you have to solve the equations
there are two things going on the
universe is expanding particles moving
away from each other but they're
exerting a gravitational force on each
other and there's a competition between
those two things
so which one wins
depends on the magnitude of the
expansion rate right
it is exactly like
taking a ball and throwing it up in the
air
right if i throw a baseball up into the
air as it goes up
the gravitational force on it is getting
weaker because its distance from the
center of the earth is increasing so the
force of gravity on the ball is getting
weaker and weaker as that ball goes up
and yet most of the time when i throw a
ball up into the air it comes down
because even though the gravitational
force is getting weaker as the ball
moves up and further away from the earth
it's only getting weaker a little bit
and its velocity is decreasing
noticeably so it just comes back
if i threw it at the escape velocity of
the earth or greater
then its gravitational force the
gravitational pull would get weaker
sufficiently fast compared to its
velocity that it would escape to
infinity the expanding universe is
exactly the same thing if the universe
is expanding really fast enough then it
will expand forever that's an open
universe and you will never have enough
time to make structure
if it's expanding slowly it could
actually not just
form structure but it would turn around
and re-collapse in a very small period
of time so for whatever reasons and
that's a whole other discussion but the
real universe had a balance or a near
balance between the gravitational pull
of particles and the expansion rate of
the universe so that the universe
expands for a very very long time but
there is enough time to form structure
anonymous says i can understand many
physical constants as we accidentally
have two units to measure one thing
seconds in meters for measuring
space-time intervals kelvins and joules
for measuring energy per particle but i
don't have a good physical intuition for
what planck's constant means momentum is
really wave number energy is really
frequency well so i think that
you have outsmarted yourself anonymous
by
understanding physical constants as
accidentally having two units to measure
one thing
so
for space and time for example you're
saying that you know we can use the
speed of light c uh to convert between
seconds and meters
but which is true
but they're not the same thing space is
not the same thing as time there's an
arrow of time there's an arrow of space
right uh there there's only one
dimension of time there are three
dimensions of space they're related
they're both different parts of
space-time but they're not the same
thing
so i think that the general strategy of
trying to understand physical constants
as measuring the same thing using
different units is not going to be a
good one planck's constant is not that
newton's constant of gravity is not that
the mass of the electron is not that
these are not conversion factors between
different but equivalent physical uh
quantities so it's not that energy is
really frequency you're thinking of the
uh famous formula e equals h
f i guess if you want to use english
letters um
roman letters uh if f is the frequency
of a wave h is planck's constant e is
the energy of a quantum of that wave and
but that doesn't mean the energy is
frequency it just means that the energy
of a quantum
of a wave at that frequency is given by
that number uh so different physical
constants do different physical things i
think you're trying to squeeze them into
too tiny of a box
chris says how have your colleagues
reacted to the amount of public
communication work that you do
well you know my colleagues are a
heterogeneous lot they've reacted in
many different ways uh i mean there's
absolutely people who don't like it
they will rarely say they don't like it
out loud because they like the idea of
public understanding of science but then
at the same time for the people who
actually do efforts in that direction
they will disparage them because they're
not spending their time doing research
and what they val what they value is the
research output
um and you know that's that's a very
real
thing
um
and it goes the other way too there are
people who love the fact that there is
uh public outreach um it's what's
interesting which what you might not
guess is that even within physicists
um you know different like if you do a
lot of different things you write
physics papers you do outreach you write
books whatever um different people know
about some subset of what you do right
so
there are people who you know are only
vaguely aware that i do outreach or
public communication or write books or
anything like that but they've read my
physics papers there are other
physicists who have no idea that i've
written any papers in the last few years
right they think i'm just writing books
um it takes you know two seconds on my
web page to figure out that i'm actually
doing both but if you're aware of one
and not the other then that's a
perfectly natural thing so
you know i think overall
um
you know i've written
plenty about this
on my blog for example there was a
semi-infamous blog post i wrote called
how to get tenure at a major research
university
um and the point being that at
at those very tiny subset of
universities known as major research
universities what they care about is the
research
um and at best you know what they will
say is well if you're good at teaching
or outreach or whatever or organizing or
community service that will count a
little bit
but it won't really help you very much
it's not most important what's most
important is research
but that's false they're they're not
telling you the truth there
they might even be lying to themselves i
don't know but the point is if you do
any of those things
um
secretly they will be thinking well they
could have been doing research during
that time and it's kind of an
interesting
weird phenomenon because if you you know
play guitar
okay if that's a hobby that you have
no one cares about that go ahead and
play guitar
but if you write books about physics
they care about that that it counts
against you and you might say well why
would playing guitar not count against
you but writing physics books count
against you in their minds they're
thinking that the time and effort that
could that you spent writing a physics
book could have been
used doing physics research
whereas the guitar playing time is just
a separate category so that doesn't
count against you so the system is
biased against you but individual people
react in a wide variety of ways as you'd
expect individual people to do
chris rogers says is there a parallel
universe where the nazis won world war
ii that seems like a shame so it's a
short question but i already have three
things i want to say in response to this
one is who cares if it seems like a
shame i'm sure that you're being
somewhat uh humorous here but of course
we want to find out what is true not
what we want to be true so whether it's
a shame or not is irrelevant whether
it's true as i'm sure you already know
uh more importantly number two
if there's a parallel universe where the
nazis won world war ii then there's a
parallel universe where world war ii
didn't even happen and that would be
awesome right i guess
uh but most importantly number three if
the parallel universes we're talking
about here
are everedian universes or different
branches of the wave function of the
universe then
it's true that there are many different
branches where many different things
happen not everything happens things
happen that have some non-zero amplitude
in the wave function of the universe
which is certainly not everything that
you can imagine
but not all universes are created
equally
and this is the absolutely crucial thing
that i've said before i'll say again
we'll always keep saying you can't
just assign sort of an equal amount of
oomph or weight
to every branch of the everedian
multiverse number one it's not what the
theory says number two it wouldn't work
empirically you would get that
probability rule wrong that we were
talking about the thick universes the
universes that have a lot of amplitude
associated with them count more and
typically and this is something which
you know it's hard to work out
quantitatively but we can sort of try to
get a feeling intuitively for what's
going on
when you're talking about big human
events these are mostly classical and
what that means is that there is
a
way that things can happen
where almost all of the amplitude ends
up right when you throw a baseball
there's some probability that it's going
to like just zoom off into space and
never come back but mostly it's going to
follow its classical trajectory both
universes are real but one is
overwhelmingly bigger and more important
than the other ones so when you think
about universes where the nazis won
world war ii or world war ii didn't
happen
it's overwhelmingly likely that these
universes have very very very very tiny
amplitudes in them
so don't worry about them honestly like
either
don't believe everybody in quantum
mechanics or don't worry about these
universes those are your two
intellectually consistent choices if you
think that ever it is right and explains
probabilities and things like that then
you should assign smaller
intellectual weight
to the branches of the wave function the
universe that have a much smaller
amplitude
brendan hall says what did you think
about barack obama's presidency
well you know it's a complicated thing a
presidency is a very big thing overall i
was positive about it positively
disposed toward it
there's a couple of complicating factors
number one is that he started off with a
very very bad hand being dealt with a
gigantic financial crisis
and a lot of uh not to mention foreign
policy crises etc so a lot of the work
was necessarily like preventing collapse
rather than building new wonderful
things
and number two you know i think that as
talented as obama was he was young right
that was a legitimate
uh worry about him when he ran for
president he didn't have the experience
that some other people had i think that
showed up in his uh and being too
optimistic about how he could get
congress to work with him and and things
like that so he accomplished less in
that sense
uh than he would have but overall my
feelings were good and look
any president who is president for eight
years or for that matter even four years
does literally thousands of things and
so of course you can pick out things and
i could pick out things that obama did
that i really really disagree with
very strongly but what has to count is
the average weight likewise when you
have someone who you like as president
you can ignore the bad things and just
count the good things because there's
just so many things going on
um i think that if you're going to try
to which i'm not doing right now by the
way but if you were going to try to do a
comprehensive and fair evaluation of
someone's presidency you can't just pick
out the best and worst things you have
to pick out everything and you also have
to be counterfactual like if this person
weren't there and there was someone else
in the white house then how things would
would things have been
in that case and i can i can imagine it
being much much worse let's put it that
way
john farr says can you speak a bit about
the virus and the vaccine
is the virus research gone wrong is bill
gates the mastermind so much
misinformation and it'll be nice to hear
your voice of reason on this one
um
so i'm not sure exactly what the
implication of this uh question is with
the virus research gone wrong and bill
gates the mastermind no i don't think
the virus research has gone wrong at all
i think it's been a brilliant success
story uh bill gates has nothing to do
with it roughly speaking i think that
when
future historians write about this era
and they say oh yeah that was the time
when they had a
major pandemic that killed hundreds and
thousands and millions of people and
they'd quickly discovered a vaccine
that would basically wipe it out but
people decided not to take it why were
they such idiots
i can't even imagine what they will be
thinking about what the rationalizations
were you know
it's okay to say well you know there's a
vaccine it's new i wonder if it works
but there's not really any disagreement
amongst credentialed experts about the
vaccine it's really really good in fact
over the overwhelming majority of
scientific studies
have been along the lines of the vaccine
is even better than we thought it was
going to be
um
so it's okay to be worried about that
but if you actually
read what sensible people are saying
it's pretty unanimous and especially
compared to
the alternative of not taking the
vaccine you're seeing now
that a
overwhelmingly
non-representative fraction of people
who are
in the hospital especially with very
serious symptoms or the unvaccinated
ones um
people who are vaccinated don't get the
virus with nearly the same rate as
vaccinated people do
um as unvaccinated people do and when
they get it the disease is not as bad
that may or may not continue to be the
case as new variants emerge etc but
right now this is not a hard question
i'm afraid it's pretty obvious
dmi says what do you mean by exist would
you say that numbers exist if you would
say that logic exists within language
what do you mean by logic
well i do think that
this is a good question to which i can't
give you a full answer i cannot give you
an answer that is completely
satisfactory because i haven't worked
out for myself what i think the answer
to this question should be i think it's
a tricky question because i think that
different things can exist in different
senses i think the most down-to-earth
sense of existence
should really be reserved for physical
reality
that's what exists and of course
different aspects of physical reality
exist also so i don't think that numbers
exist or logic exists in the same way
that physical reality exists uh but
there's some
some reality some umph some power some
non-arbitrariness to numbers and logic
that is very important i just don't
think it should be given the same label
existence in the same way that the
physical world exists i'm a reality
realist as i'd like to say
leah reichfault says
what are your preferred sources of
information for news and informing your
worldview more generally
so again i don't i don't think this is a
hard question i think that most
straightforward mainstream news media
mostly do a good job at reporting facts
um not a perfect job by all means as
someone who has you know uh read stories
in news media about science
things that i know very well i know
perfectly well that media can get things
wrong okay but in basic things that are
happening in the world like there was
you know a building that fell down i
believe what the mainstream media says
about those things
um i certainly don't believe conspiracy
theories where the media is trying to
mislead you there's a very there's a set
of very real
critiques of the mainstream media
dealing not with uh what it factually
reports but what it number one what it
chooses to report and not report
and number two the spin that it puts on
reporting things and not reporting
things but that's a very long
complicated uh non-trivial conversation
if you think you have simple answers to
those then i'm already going to disagree
with you i think it's complicated
um
but so in addition to that i think that
is good because you know even mainstream
media has its its blind spots and its
biases it's good to have a variety so
for
what i do for that and again nothing
very profound about my own personal
technique but that's where i find social
media very useful you know following a
lot of different accounts on social
media from a wide spectrum of different
points of view and different interests
will help point you to things that might
not have appeared in the mainstream
media and you should always be a little
bit more skeptical of those but you can
you know again
get a feeling for how credible they are
etc so i get sort of most of my news
from conventional sources but then i try
to keep a lot of um people i trust in
the me social media feed so i can get
pointed to things that i would not
necessarily have come across if i were
just reading the new york times
or the wall street journal or whatever
it was
adrian says around 10 years ago you
wrote an illuminating blog post about
how energy is not necessarily conserved
in cosmology are there ways to harness
usable energy from that at least in
principle roughly speaking that's
probably a complicated question but
roughly speaking the answer is no
there could always be loopholes that i
haven't thought of here but the point is
that energy is not conserved in
cosmology at least the energy of stuff
is not conserved in cosmology because
the
existence of general relativity where
space-time is dynamical and responds to
matter and energy means that the total
amount of energy rather than just being
a constant
obeys a relationship with the curvature
of space-time okay
so space-time expanding or contracting
or doing other things can change the
amount of energy in matter and radiation
and to be useful you know you say usable
energy if you're here on earth space
time isn't changing that much right uh
so
to the in the approximation where space
time is static which is a really good
approximation here on earth then energy
is conserved so i don't see any useful
way to get uh anything from that
subtlety of general relativity
okay i'm gonna group two questions
together because they're about the
matter antimatter asymmetry in the
universe clyde schechter says there are
two diffic there are two
difficult to explain asymmetries in
physics that i struggle with
understanding one is the macroscopic
existence of an arrow of time when the
laws of physics on the micro scale are
invariant under time reversal the other
is the predominance of matter
over antimatter again nothing in the
micro laws of physics calls for this my
question is whether these two
asymmetries are related in some deep way
and the other is from sam cartford who
says question on bariogenesis i've heard
two potential theories explained one
being there is an asymmetry between
matter and antimatter in the physics of
the early universe
and the second being that we can only
exist in the universe with this
discrepancy so we might just exist in a
statistical anomaly so something like
the anthropic principle
uh so to sam's question that second
possibility that there's just a
statistical anomaly no no one believes
that no no credible person believes that
number one i don't know where the
statistical anomaly would come from but
number two
you know whenever you run these
anthropic arguments
the the correct thing to do is to say
there's a distribution of possible
configurations of stuff environments
situations in the universe
and living creatures will only exist in
those particular configurations where
life is possible okay so to do this at
all there's a selection effect you're
only observing those circumstances under
which life can exist and observers can
be found
but you need a distribution you need to
know how many of one kind of situations
there are versus how many other kinds of
situations there are
and therefore
when you need some kind of fluctuation
to let life exist
generally the anthropic principle would
predict absent any other mechanism that
they predict that the fluctuation will
be as small as it needs to be to get
life to exist whereas in our observable
universe there's 100 billion galaxies or
a trillion galaxies and they're all
matter they're not all anti-matter
that would be a much much much much much
bigger fluctuation than you would need
for life to exist
so
it could be that the asymmetry between
matter and antimatter is just baked into
the initial conditions of the universe
but it's much more likely and much more
popular to think that there is some like
you say asymmetry in the dynamics of
matter and antimatter that created that
difference so clyde is asking whether
that asymmetry could have anything to do
with the arrow of time
uh not that i know of you know there is
um
they are there
the arrow of time in the sense of
irreversible processes processes
existing in the universe is because
entropy is increasing um to get an
asymmetry in matter versus antimatter
you need to violate what is called time
reversal invariance which is not quite
the same thing
time reversal invariance can be violated
and is violated by the fundamental laws
of physics as we understand them without
violating reversibility so things can go
one way but still have the property that
you know exactly where they came from so
remember the ice cube melting into a
glass of water the irreversibility comes
from the fact that
given the final state a cool glass of
water you don't know where it came from
you don't know whether it came from a
cool glass of water 10 minutes ago or
whether it was a warm glass of water
with an ice cube in it whereas in
particle physics there is t violation t
being the time reversal
operator but everything is still
reversible it's unitary evolution smooth
reversible evolution from one state to
another
but that is all you need or that is one
of the things you need you need that
kind of time reversal um
violation in order to get a baryon
asymmetry more baryons than anti-baryons
as far as i know
there's i mean sorry
you do also need it as andre sakurov
pointed this out back in the 60s you
also need a departure from thermal
equilibrium which does rely on the arrow
of time so i guess the right thing to
say is that
getting a baryon asymmetry requires an
arrow of time but an arrow time does not
require baryon asymmetry or any of the
other ingredients for getting a baryon
asymmetry so if anything their
connection goes one way but not the
other
kathy seeger says i've read that in june
2021 british astronomer alexia lopez and
team discovered a so-called giant arc a
structure of galaxies spanning 3.3
billion light years it was said that
this wouldn't go along with the
cosmological principle that matter on a
large scale is evenly distributed
throughout the universe is there an
explanation that could align cosmic
inflation in unevenly distributed matter
so
two things here one is i haven't read
the paper i haven't read the specific
example so i can't
comment on the giant arc or whatever it
is um
but number two there's essentially zero
chance that the distribution of matter
in the universe is flagrantly at
violation with the cosmological
principle that matter is evenly
distributed the reason why is because we
have the cosmic microwave background
right the cosmic microwave background is
much more precise and easy to measure
than the distribution of galaxies and
it's super duper isotropic it looks the
same in every direction if matter
through the universe was distributed
very non-uniformly
you would know because the microwave
background would reflect that
even if it just through gravitational
lensing etc so i'm 99.999
confident that any
distribution that you find in galaxies
or collections of galaxies will
ultimately be compatible with
more or less
cosmological uh homogeneity on very
large scales it's not perfect right it's
it's a it's a good approximation but
it's a very good approximation
okay i'm going to group two questions
together ulrich scheibe says the marvel
cinematic universe loki series as well
as upcoming spider-man and doctor
strange movies are diving headfirst into
the multiverse
the explanation for how this fictional
multiverse works was explained to loki
at some point in the broader lines seem
to be heavily influenced by many worlds
theory you mentioned once that you had a
small part to play in avengers end game
have you been consulted again if so do
elaborate on your involvement if you can
and rob kraft says i recently re-read
the novel dune by frank herbert in
preparation for the upcoming movie
this is the first time i've read it
since becoming familiar with many worlds
it occurred to me that herbert's
description of paul atreides's ability
to see the future and possible timelines
aligns with the everettian idea of the
branching of the universe do you think
herbert who published dune in 1965 could
have known the everetti interpretation
and used that as the basis for his
explanation of paul's ability to see the
future so i'm grouping these together
for the obvious reasons that they're
connecting uh
storytelling versions of the multiverse
idea and asking if there's a connection
with the evaretti and quantum mechanical
version and i want to emphasize that if
there is any connection it's a very very
tenuous one
you know these are stories these are in
fact fantasy stories even though they're
gussied up in some science fiction
elements
um
the the authors just make up the story
the rules of the game
for dramatic purposes okay
maybe they were inspired a little bit by
everett and quantum mechanics or by the
cosmological multiverse etc i don't know
um but they don't need to be you could
easily come up with these ideas without
that particular inspiration and
certainly the actual ways in which
um
they implement the multiverses in both
cases
are nothing to do with ever ready in
quantum mechanics now i did i can reveal
that when i was talking to the folks in
avengers you know i got some
advice in there that was taken about
time travel
but i had you know a more elaborate
scheme for fixing the whole universe um
so my idea was that there really were
branching timelines remember you know
when the hulk goes back to talk to the
ancient one played by tilda swinton and
she gives him a spiel about the one
timeline and the other timelines and
that is elaborated on in loki which is a
great series by the way if you haven't
seen it um
so the metaphor that is kind of used in
the marvel cinematic multiverse is
pruning the other timelines right
getting rid of them somehow so my idea
was that that would be terrible because
that's literally committing genocide
right you're literally ending the lives
of trillions and trillions of people
living in this timeline and that should
be bad that should be considered to be
immoral if anything is
um and therefore a better thing to do
would be to re-merge the timelines again
this can't happen in the real world i
made it up but i thought it'd be
interesting to imagine that the
difficult task that they faced was to
sort of
line up what was physically happening in
all the different branches of the
multiverse so that things once again
came together to make one big branch
therefore you could sort of preserve a
single timeline without literally
committing genocide and killing a bunch
of people
that i think that was too conceptually
complicated uh and subtle for them to go
with so they didn't um but still there's
a novel out there waiting to be written
that has that idea in it
tim kennedy says i've long been curious
about the mass of the proton i've been
taught and can accept that it comes
mostly from the binding energy of the
quarks inside but in a recent ama you
characterize the inside of the proton as
a roiling soup of quarks that are
appearing and disappearing but with a
constant instantaneous average of three
quarks
i had convinced myself that having
exactly three quarks constantly racing
around at near light speed could result
in a very large binding energy but now i
am confused again
maybe i should not be imagining the mass
of the proton as something resulting
from classical mechanics
so once again a lot going on in this
question um first i have no idea what i
said in the last ama i
my short-term memory and my long-term
memory both very bad so forget what i
said um i certainly would not want to
characterize the inside of a proton as a
roiling soup of quarks appearing and
disappearing
what i really like to emphasize over and
over again is that in quantum field
theory
the state of something like a proton
is static
there's nothing changing there's nothing
roiling there's nothing appearing
disappearing inside a proton
we speak about it using a sloppy
language of virtual particles appearing
and disappearing but what really is
there is just a fixed constant status
static quantum field configuration
if you force yourself to interpret
this quantum field configuration as a
collection of particles i'm not forcing
you to do that but if you just insist
uh and you imagine drawing fineman
diagrams representing what's going on
the feynman diagrams
would look like a bunch of particles
popping in out of existence
but the sum of all of them would be a
static unchanging field configuration so
quantum field theory really matters here
that's one thing
the other thing is the extra energy so
the point of this question is that if
you calculate the mass of a loan all by
itself quark okay
that's a tricky thing to define because
there's no such thing as an all by
itself quark quarks are confined inside
bigger particles but you can do it you
can do something like it
and the masses of the three particles
that go the three quarks that going to
make a proton are less by a lot than the
mass of the proton okay
so the mass of the proton doesn't come
from the mass of the quarks it comes
from the energy
contained in the
gluon field in the uh strong interaction
analog of the electric and magnetic
fields so here's the way you should
think about it imagine there was an
electron so forget about quarks because
quarks are complicated take an electron
and imagine that you could turn off the
electric field of the electron okay you
can't but imagine you could
and the electron has a mass
then all by itself an uncharged electron
has a certain mass
and now gradually turn back on
the electric field well it takes energy
to turn on the electric field to create
that electric field out of nowhere
so
equals mc squared
the the energy contained in a motionless
particle a particle at rest is
what we call the mass divided by the
speed times the speed of light squared
is is the energy
and so
you have more mass there's more energy
and therefore more mass there's a
there's a contribution to the mass of
the of the particle from its electric
field
and physicists argue about you know
renormalizing this and what counts as
what et cetera et cetera but the point
is there is energy and therefore mass
contained in the electric field as well
as in the bare mass of the electron by
itself
and one reason you know this picture
works is because
if you take an electron and a proton
and you bring them together they make
hydrogen and it's a stable configuration
it takes energy to remove
the
electron from the proton and the reason
why is because the electrons electric
field has energy the protons electric
field has energy but when you bring them
together at large distances they cancel
and they have no energy
so there is less energy
in the combination of electron and
proton than there was in the separate
electron plus the separate proton
because both of those guys had electric
fields which carry energy and when you
combine them the electric field mostly
cancels and the energy goes away
exactly the same story is true for
quarks in a proton now you have three
quarks in the proton two ups and it down
they're different colors
but if you took a quark all by itself it
would have a field a gluon field a
quantum chromodynamic field which is the
quark equivalent the strong interaction
equivalent of the electric field around
the electron okay
the difference is and this is the
crucial difference that makes a strong
interaction special
just like you take the mass of the
electron and then add to it the energy
from its electric field
you take the mass of the quark and then
you add to it the energy from its
quantum chromodynamic field but that
energy is infinite
if you had a lone quark all by itself
the energy in the gluon field around it
would be infinitely big
however if you have three quarks all of
different colors
then just like the electron and the
proton
the
fields cancel out at infinity so you get
a finite energy remaining a finite
little remnant energy in the gluon
fields of the three quarks that are
combined together to make the proton
that's why you can't take a quark out of
the proton because it would require an
infant amount of energy to have a cork
all by itself
but inside the quark there's still some
energy from the leftover quantum
chromodynamic field and it's from that
energy that the proton gets its mass the
proton does not get its mass because the
electrons are or the the quarks are
moving they're not moving they're in
their ground state they're in their
lowest energy states it's from the
quantum chromodynamic field that carries
some energy most of the energy in the
proton or likewise the neutron etc
okay grouping two questions together one
is from p walder who says critical
rationalists such as david deutsch seem
to suggest that induction cannot be a
valid approach to gaining access to
truth about reality they also seem to
suggest that bayesianism is dressed up
induction can you explain why you feel
bayesianism is a better approach to
understanding the nature of reality than
hard to vary explanations that are
advocated by critical rationalists
and jeff b says are there any
convictions that you hold about the
universe that are not based in
scientific evidence but just feel right
to you okay these two questions might
seem different but they're gonna i'm
gonna relate them the point being i'm
not very familiar with deutsche's
argument as to why bayesianism doesn't
work and um something else does work
he's a more pupperian i know that um but
i haven't read his stuff very carefully
i'm only very vaguely familiar with it
so i can't comment on what david deutsch
is saying so i'm not going to say it yes
or no i can try to
justify what i want to say
because what i want to say is the
opposite of saying bayesianism is
dressed up induction i want to say that
popparianism falsificationism is dressed
down bayesianism
so to say that you have to be clear
about what you mean by bayesianism
because bayesianism comes in two parts
one is bayes's rule right the formula or
basis theorem or basis law or whatever
you want to call it
that's a theorem
that's a mathematical result it's just a
statement about how probability works if
you're dealing with a set of quantities
that obey the axioms of probability then
bayes's rule is just true for those
quantities those probabilities so you
can't there's no option there there's no
other way to do it
the the part where things become a
little bit more
potentially controversial is
not the formalism of bases rule but the
meaning you attach to those
probabilities okay
when where you go from just applying
bass's rule to sort of
doing bayesian reasoning
is in the step where you say okay to
every proposition i think of i attach a
prior
i give a prior credence or a prior
probability that that is true and then i
learn more about the world by looking at
the world
right doing experiments gathering data
calculating the likelihood that in this
if these propositions that i'm thinking
about were true i would have collected
that data and then using bayes's law to
update my credences from priors to
posteriors
so the tricky thing that not everyone
agrees with is the idea that we get
reasoning off the ground by starting
with a collection of priors about
different things it's a very subjective
way of doing probabilities you're
thinking of probabilities as degrees of
belief as credences
rather than as frequencies of things
happening and to a bayesian like myself
it's hard to imagine doing it any other
way like if you say what is the
probability
that it will rain tomorrow here where i
am in boston it's pretty high because
we're at the remnants of a hurricane
coming um but
it's gonna rain or it's not like there's
no frequency involved there right it's a
degree of belief it's the best
prediction i can make him the
information i get so two bayesians this
is just how how to work and there's
really no other alternative
um but a lot of people react against the
idea that these that probabilities
should be something fundamentally
subjective different people can have
different priors and that bugs them now
that's not what is bugging i think david
deutsch et cetera um the problem of
induction a well-known problem that
david hume and other people talked about
a lot about is
you can't prove things with metaphysical
certainty just by observing a lot of
instances right
can you prove that all swans are white
well
you observe every single swan and
they're all white okay have you proven
it well unless you've literally seen
every single possible swan it is always
possible that tomorrow you'll see a
black swan
and therefore you're you haven't proven
anything okay
so i would say that bayesianism is not
dressed up induction bayesianism is the
fix to that problem
because
sure you're not proving with
metaphysical certainty that all swans
are white but you start with a prior
that either swans are white all the time
or there's another prior on the creed on
the proposition that some swans are
white and some are black you used those
theories to make predictions for what
the color of the next one you're going
to see is you update your your
credences as you get more data in but
the critical thing is your credences
never go to zero right you can see a
billion white swans in a row you still
have some non-zero credence that some
swans are black because if some swans
were black but only one out of a billion
there would be some probability some
likelihood that that's what you would
have seen
so
you don't run into this problem that
that induction runs into because you're
not trying to prove things with
metaphysical certainty you're just
updating your credences as you get more
information
now
the paparian falsification way of doing
things and again i haven't read carl
popper in any detail either so you pop
aryans out there don't get mad at me i'm
discussing not really what popper said
but sort of the
cartoon popper that a lot of scientists
carry around with them this idea is that
you list every possible thing that could
be true
and you don't assign prior probabilities
to them credences to them you just say
it could be true or it it either is true
or isn't i don't know yet
and then you do experiments you collect
data and you figure out
this piece of data is incompatible with
that theory therefore it's false it's
been falsified
and so rather than having a large list
of propositions and assigning credences
to them you have a large even maybe even
larger list of propositions and some of
them falsified and some of them have not
and that's it that's what you're allowed
to say if you haven't falsified anything
then it's not yet falsified that's all
you're allowed to say to me that's just
a crude approximation to being a good
bayesian okay
because in reality
we don't assign equal prior credences to
every possible proposition and that it
would be crazy i think to do that no one
does it no one should do it why pretend
that that's what we're doing
um or even failing i guess no one would
say you should apply equal credences but
some people say just don't apply
credences i think that also fails i
think you have to apply credences they
might be implicit you might not be very
uh above board about it but implicitly
you're doing that all the time and
that's why i'm grouping this question
with jeff's question are there any
convictions that are not based on
scientific evidence that just feel right
to me so the short answer is no i mean
the principled answer is no you know i
don't it's
i do have
um
beliefs degrees of belief credences for
how the universe works
but i'm willing to update them okay um
and it's you know to say they're not
based in scientific evidence is is hard
to exactly countenance because
these these beliefs came from somewhere
usually from observing other things
about the world and saying well you know
this sort of extrapolates beyond what
i've seen to other things that i think
are right
so mostly
i don't have any convictions about the
universe that are not based in
scientific evidence i do have prior
probabilities
the one
counter example or loophole to that is
that
there are some
propositions which if they were true
science itself would not be possible
right if i were being taunted by an evil
demon and all of my sense data were
completely unrelated to the reality of
the world then
i'm not able to do science at all right
or if i were a boltzmann brain that just
fluctuated into existence so these are
self-undermining or cognitively unstable
beliefs about the world and so i have a
prior probability that it's essentially
zero
that those are true it can't even be
exactly zero because maybe the demon
walks through the door and says huh see
i've been fooling you this whole time
you never know but you keep that
probability so so so low to begin with
that you don't take it seriously unless
you're forced into it later on
brian f carpenter says i've been trying
to find out the orientation of the milky
way galaxy in relation to the origin of
the universe or big bang event and more
broadly the orientation of space-time
and general relativity in other words if
space-time is like the fabric of a
trampoline how do we know on which plane
it's stretched and why
so i have to unask this question brian
because space-time is not like the
fabric of a trampoline you know when we
visualize again i've already
said bad things about our tendency to
need to visualize things earlier on but
some things are not visualizable space
time is four-dimensional it's not
two-dimensional like a trampoline
a trampoline or a sheet of rubber or
whatever has the feature that it is
embedded in a bigger space
if you treat the trampoline as
two-dimensional it's embedded in
three-dimensional space therefore if you
take the trampoline analogy too
seriously you begin to think that
space-time
is embedded in something but it's not
so there's no such thing as the
orientation of space-time with respect
to what would it be oriented i don't i
don't even know what it could possibly
be oriented with so
i would just undo the premises of your
questions um
there is a more down-to-earth question
you know that you get to which is like
you have a bunch of galaxies a bunch of
stars a bunch of uh solar systems and
they have angular momentum right they're
spinning so there's some plane in which
things are aligned
and is there some universal lining up of
these planes like do different galaxies
still orbit in the same direction and
the answer there as far as anyone knows
is no people looked at that a little bit
not very carefully but we're
we're so sort of convinced theoretically
that it'd be weird for that to be true
uh it's not a high priority for people
to collect data and look at it when they
have they found no evidence that there
is any general alignment of different
things in the universe
brian owenson says you recently tweeted
that most of the mass in your body is
made of particles containing 48 quarks
you must be referring to an oxygen atom
are there any interesting questions that
are better addressed by thinking of an
oxygen nucleus as a pool of 48 quarks as
opposed to thinking about the nucleus as
a pool of separate protons and neutrons
uh so there's a couple things going on
just to be strictly clear
you say oxygen atom but what you mean is
oxygen nucleus it's the nucleus that is
made up of 48 quarks the reason why i
made that quip on twitter is because
people were as they occasionally do
getting excited about
tetraquarks or other collections of new
new collections previously undis
discovered collections of quarks that
you can find at large hadron collider or
wherever
um and it's great you know this is
important science don't get me wrong
it's important to do this to learn about
quarks and qcd and the strong
interactions and how they fit together
but i worry that people are getting
excited just because there's more than
three quarks in this particle
okay
we have plenty of particles with more
than three quarks in them every atomic
nucleus is a particle with more than
three quarks in them and so that's why i
picked oxygen because most of your body
mass is in the form of oxygen nuclei
um
the point being that you how do you
define particle
there's two choices one is you say oh
only the elementary particles count
in which case it's only quarks that
count protons and neutrons do not count
as particles under that definition
the other definition you could use which
is also perfectly good is a bound
collection of particles of fundamental
particles can be counted as a
composite particle in that case
mesons and baryons like pions and
protons and neutrons those are all
composite particles perfectly good
definition also but under that
definition
atomic nuclei are composite particles
so you say
are there conditions under which you
should think of an oxygen nucleus as 48
quarks rather than separate protons and
neutrons
yeah all of the conditions
this is sort of a secret of nuclear
physics that does not become clear when
you look at little cartoon images of
nuclei because when you draw cartoon
images of let's say hydrogen nucleus
sorry hydrogen is not a good example
helium two protons and two neutrons
you tend to draw separate protons and
neutrons but that's not what the nucleus
looks like it's just a spherical blob
and the spherical blob has all the
quarks and neutrons um arranged in it
not exactly equally because there's a
pauli exclusion principle um but they're
not confined separately to protons and
neutrons which then combine into nuclei
they're all in the nucleus
that's how they have you know names for
like the nuclear drop model and things
like that the bag model
but you shouldn't think of protons and
neutrons in a nucleus as having separate
identities anymore that's all just a sea
of quarks david gotti says priority
question my son is about to start a
master's program in physics and would
like to get a phd after that much of his
undergraduate work was in astronomy and
physics influenced by his key professors
work on galaxies and he made poster
session presentations at the annual
american astronomical society conference
however he is open to other fields
within physics he has not been strongly
introduced to yet
can you discuss and give advice for him
how to use his master's work to best set
himself up to be a strong phd applicant
and how his loved ones can best support
that so
it's a bit of an unusual question
actually david because most in the
united states anyway which is where i'm
uh familiar with what goes on
most people who get phds don't go from
undergraduate to masters to phd they do
a right from undergraduate program to
phd program that's the much more common
route to go you pick up a master's along
the way like after two years they just
say oh yeah here's a master's degree no
big deal but it's not a separate step
so it's perfectly okay to go to a
master's program first but i'm just
saying it's not the common route so i'm
not as good at offering advice about
what to do because it doesn't happen
that often
um i mean in fact what i would say is
this roughly
who cares that he's getting a master's
what matters is he's going to be
applying for phd programs so the
question is not what should you do in
your master's program to prepare you
your question is just how to be the best
possible applicant to a phd program
whether or not you have a master's
degree
when you apply to phd programs again i
can only speak for the u.s because
different countries are very different
usually
you indicate a preference for a group to
be a part of so you'll have a department
physics department right but they'll be
different groups within the department
theoretical particle physics
experimental particle physics
theoretical astrophysics uh
observational astronomy
theoretical condensed matter physics
biophysics etc right they're individual
groups and there are different faculty
members associated with those groups
you might think that either you apply to
the department or you very specifically
say who you want your phd advisor to be
but neither one is true you typically
say i would like to be in this group
and then you get there and when you're
there and in the group you sort of talk
to the different faculty in the group
and eventually settle on one as your
advisor
so that's the sort of
mindset that an applicant should have
they need to know what kind of group
they want to be in by the time you're
entering grad school
you shouldn't be undecided about that
anymore you don't need to be decided
about
what exact research project you're going
to do or even deciding between like
string theory and particle physics or
something like that things that are
within the same group okay
but you do need to decide what group
you're going to be in because different
groups might have different numbers of
people they can accept different
standards you know different amount of
funding available for new students
things like that
so
it doesn't matter that much what
research you did before you were a phd
student whether it's undergraduate or
masters it's good that you've done
research
doing research is a good thing but
especially if you're going to do highly
theoretical things in grad school but
even if not
um it's generally understood that people
will do different research in the phd
program than they did before
what's much more important is getting
good letters of recommendation okay
that's the single most important i
should say that first if i were if i
were front loading the important thing
the important thing to use that master's
degree for
is to have
faculty members ideally faculty members
who will be known
to people in the graduate in the phd
programs they'll eventually apply to
get to know
the student very very well well enough
to really write a good letter of
recommendation for them that can be
explicit about why they're a strong
applicant it's also nice to get good gre
scores and grades and so forth but if
you really want to put your research
time to work while you're a master's
student
you know it's i see it all the time
where people apply to grad school and no
faculty member
knows them well enough to write a good
letter and that's that's bad that's a
shame uh because that's really useful
information for the admissions committee
so i guess the two things to do are
number one
get to know faculty members well enough
they can write you good letters number
two choose what group you want to be in
when you apply to the phd programs and
then you can hopefully find a group with
many different faculty members in it and
once you're there
once your son is there
decide which of them might make a good
advisor
jesse rimler says worker-owned
cooperatives are examples of extending
democracy into the workplace as a fan of
democracy are you interested in a
similar extension of democracy into
scientific institutions
you know i think roughly it's already
there
it's too late
you know science is not an autocracy
there's no pope or emperor of science
you know science is run by scientists as
a collective and
it's not very formal right you don't
make
elections you don't vote on whether this
theory is true or not but individual
scientists make up their mind and they
vote with their feet
they vote with deciding what to do
research on and what papers to write and
who to hire and things like that that's
how they make the voting and you know
they can be department chair or whatever
but who cares being a department chair
means you decide who gets what office it
doesn't mean you decide what scientific
results are true okay
science is very democratic this is part
of the the wonder of how science works
is that ideas bubble up from the bottom
and you need to convince people that
you're right just like you do in a
democracy so i am a fan of exactly that
bk says
a lot of academics have dissected the
show the chair
which is on uh where is the chair on is
it on netflix or hbo i forget anyway
they dissected it on twitter down to the
decor in the buildings office etc with
reference to how realistic they look
what do you think of the representation
of caltech in films and tv shows such as
the big bang theory
so i have a small muse anecdote to say
about this i've said it before so
apologies like i only have a finite
number of stories to tell so those of
you who listen to me too much are going
to hear them all several times
um
my friend david salzberg was the
official science advisor on the big bang
theory david is uh
an experimental particle physicist at
ucla and and they really took the
science advising seriously you know way
more than most science shows on uh cable
tv dude let's put it that way um what
that what it means is that all the
science dialogue and all of the
equations on the whiteboards etc were
from david and he made absolutely sure
they were accurate even if they were
hypothesizing they were hypothesizing in
plausible ways
so that's good even though most people
wouldn't really care to be honest um but
what was more interesting is before the
show ever started they were designing
the sets right this is what you're
asking about how the places look
and
they had these ideas like you know you
would see a lab like you saw in the
avengers right or you know you seen any
of
these science fiction shows of very
high-tech glossy things with you know
gleaming lens flare and chrome and
whatever and then so david salzberg said
well i'll take you on a tour of the labs
in the physics department at ucla
and the set designers were appalled
they're like oh my god this place is a
dump you're blocking your lasers with a
a piece of cardboard attached to a
clothespin this is not very high tech at
all of course because you know you have
a limited budget and you want to
stretch the budget as far as you can you
don't spend your actual science dollars
on a gleaming all futuristic looking
laboratory equipment
so that got reflected if you look at the
lab scenes in the big bang theory
they're actually much more realistic
than most other scenes
the other thing i can say along those
lines is a slight faux pas on my part i
was once consulting on the tv show bones
there was a um
murder mystery where the confu the
accused murderer was a theoretical
physicist played by richard schiff
famous as toby from the west wing and so
i got to write some of his dialogue and
uh um
yeah in fact some of the things he says
have to do with uh entropy in the arrow
of time as you will see in robertson
walker cosmologies um and also write
blackboards which turned out to be an
important
uh plot point on the show the blackboard
so if you see this show if you want if
you want to google the episode of bones
with richard schiff as a guest star um
i forget what the title of the show was
but look it's actually really extremely
well done like there's not a dry eye in
the house at the end of this show and
the your mistiness will be because of
equations believe it or not i'm not
going to give away more than that um but
the point is you know i walked onto the
set they had me visit and i walked onto
the set and it's a typical hollywood
version of a professor's office right
like big overstuff leather chair
elaborate desk all these books that look
like they're from 150 years ago
and i couldn't help myself i'm like yep
this is a very hollywood looking
physicist's office
real physicist office don't look like
that they're usually pretty spartan
affairs the walls are often cinderblock
with a coat of paint
the books are not from 150 years ago the
chairs are not leather-bound let's put
it all that way
and i felt bad because the set designer
was there and they were they were
you know hurt because they tried to do a
good job and they had no idea what a
real physicist office looked like i mean
they're much smaller than what the tv
show had also so i you know i at least
said well let's put some more modern
looking books on here or something like
that um
it turns out to be hard to do because
modern looking books you might need to
get
rights to show them on tv et cetera et
cetera et cetera my third story i don't
know why i'm giving all these stories
but um my third story along those lines
is on the tv show fringe i also
consulted a little bit and a friend of
mine glenn whitman was one of the
writers on the show and so he had me he
has asked me some questions about
wormholes and things like that
and uh i gave him answers and so as a
reward usually you don't get rewarded
for this at all you certainly don't get
paid for any of this that's for sure so
my reward was
he said uh there's a scene in the in the
script where you know someone is passing
a book to someone else will make it one
of your books we'll we'll invent a book
that you haven't written you know but
we'll say you wrote so they invented a
book called cosmology by me and you know
uh
uh john noble's character says have you
stolen my copy of carol's cosmology or
something like that you know they have
they have a book like someone the set
designer made a book with my name on the
title etc
and only afterward you know this is
before i'd written most of my trade
books but only afterwards i say like i
wrote a general relativity textbook they
could have just used that i could have
advertised my actual book instead of let
them use a fake book
but no one said i was very smart about
these things my branding needs a little
uh upgrading what can i do all right
that was a much longer question answered
than you needed for that question but
it's a good question
paul hess says i believed you once
mentioned that entanglement leads to or
causes increased entropy can you explain
this connection a little more detail as
entropy always increases in the universe
does entanglement also increase in
similar proportions so
i'm going to have to apologize because i
do say things like that and i try to be
careful when i'm saying them but there
are
nuances and details that get glossed
over
there are different kinds of entropy
when i say that the entropy of the
universe was low near the big bang and
it's been growing ever since i really
mean
some kind of coarse-grained ludwig
boltzmann kind of entropy which means
that there is a system which is the
universe and there are many many
different microstates the system can be
in
and we group together many of those
microstates into a macro state count
them take the logarithm and that's the
entropy that is a kind of entropy there
is another kind of entropy that exists
in quantum mechanics that boltzmann
didn't know about it boltzmann didn't
know about quantum mechanics and this
kind of entropy was invented by john von
neumann and it's called either the
neumann entropy or the entanglement
entropy
and it's
called entropy because it is entropy
it's a very similar conceptual thing it
has very similar looking equations but
it is a different thing because
entanglement exists in quantum mechanics
and doesn't exist in classical mechanics
so the point is this
if you have a system
where you know what macrostate it's in
okay so you have a glass of water a
bunch of molecules in there etc but you
don't know its microstate
entropy becomes useful because you can
give a probability distribution to all
the different possible microstates right
you can say well i'm sure the system has
some particular
position and momentum and orientation of
every single molecule but i don't know
what they are so i'm going to talk about
a probability distribution okay
so the difference between knowing the
exact microstate and just knowing the
probability distribution we call the
former a pure state it's an actual
[Music]
particular realization of the positions
and velocities of all the molecules that
laplace's demon could work with and we
call a mixed state the idea there's a
probability distribution over all the
different possibilities so the same
thing is true in quantum mechanics you
can have a pure state which is described
by a wave function
you could also have a mixed state which
is described by some sort of probability
distribution over different pure states
the difference that i'm finally getting
to in quantum mechanics is
when you have
two systems
and they are entangled with each other
remember the whole point of entanglement
is that the two subsystems don't have a
wave function all by themselves there is
only one wave function the wave function
of the universe and if you just want to
isolate your focus down onto two systems
that are not entangled with the rest of
the universe but maybe with each other
then those two systems have a single
composite wave function okay
so if they're entangled with each other
then it is automatically true that even
if you know the exact wave function of
the complete two system thing
two subsystem system if you want there
is no single wave function for either of
the constituents
okay they're both automatically in a
mixed state you can describe if it's a
and b if it's alice and bob and they
have their particles and the particles
are entangled
there is no wave function for alice's
particle there's no wave function for
bob's particle there's just a wave
function for both
there's no state there's no pure state
for particle a or for particle b but you
can assign a mixed state to particle a
and particle b it's as if
if you didn't know the particle a was
entangled you would say that particle a
is in a combination not a superposition
but like a statistical mixture of
different possible quantum states and
therefore it has an entropy
so the thing that is new
is that in quantum mechanics
entanglement can lead to an entropy of
subsystems
even if you know the exact state of the
composite system as a whole
um having said all that okay that's the
connection
does entanglement increase as the
universe goes on well that's a
complicated thing i want to say roughly
yes i would not go into any more details
than that but the details are
interesting and i don't think we
understand all of those details
precisely that's one of the reasons why
i want to be vague here
brad malt says in your podcast taking
aliens seriously avilobe says that alien
visitors may possess technologies so
advanced that they would look like magic
to us and miracles we cannot really
understand his logic is that our own
technologies are evolving exponentially
so imagine what a civilization with a
few hundred thousand or millions of
years could do
what is the coolest magic you could
think that advanced civilizations might
possess
and do you think this could be any of
the following
the ability to connect with other
branches of the multiverse the ability
to travel near the speed of light the
ability to travel backward or forward in
time or the ability to make use of
dimensions greater than four that are
currently accessible to us
okay so the reason why i wanted to
answer this question is because this
very interesting list of possibilities
uh actually these you have four
possibilities connecting with other
branches multiverse travel near the
speed of light travel backward forward
in time make use of extra dimensions
these have very different statuses these
questions okay are these these
possibilities so the ability to travel
near the speed of light absolutely of
course
we can do that with individual particles
we accelerate particles near the speed
of light
to accelerate a spaceship to near the
speed of light it's just a technology
problem like that's that's very very
solvable
um
whereas the ability to connect with
other branches of the multiverse we
think is strictly impossible there's
nothing you can do
uh in this branch of the multiverse to
connect with any other branches
likewise when you travel backward or
forward in time well backward and
forward aren't created equal here
we travel forward in time all the time i
traveled forward in time yesterday by 24
hours and here i am you can even get
there faster by moving near the speed of
light whereas as far as we know you just
can't travel backward in time now we
don't know that for 100 sure
uh check out the podcast i did with kip
thorne for more on that but it seems the
smart way to bet is that you cannot
travel backward in time and for
dimensions greater than four um
number one we don't know if they exist
okay but number two i would so this is
this is a tricky one because
if they do exist
it's not against the laws of physics to
imagine
using them somehow technologically but
it is
almost against everything we know about
how they would work the energies that
would be required to manipulate them
uh are just enormous and then they would
relax back to their ordinary state so i
even though it's not strictly speaking
against the laws of physics i see no way
for advanced civilization to make use of
extra dimensions uh in any practical way
okay
two questions i'm going to group
together
one is by justin bailey who says after
listening to the podcast on
with edward singerland slingerland uh i
would really like to know what the flow
state is like for you are equations
pouring out on the page paragraphs just
appearing magically and what does the
flow for a cosmologist quantum theorist
like yourself feel like
and then daniel fox says do you find
concepts such as huawei affect your
approaches to creative thinking about
theoretical physics so very very closely
related questions
um
i'm not an expert on what really counts
as that but i think you know many of us
have had the experience that we've been
in the zone
in that flow state and certainly that
happens with theoretical physics and
actually it's a really good question to
ask what that means right if you're
painting or if you're playing a musical
instrument or if you're playing sports
or something like that
or even if you're driving
you
it's very clear what you mean to say
that you're in this flow state you're
sort of not consciously fretting about
the details you know it's just happening
automatically and we know as modern
scientists that there are things going
on in your brain but those things are
just not penetrating to the conscious
cognitive system to part of your brain
they're all subconscious system one
things going on
when it comes to physics
how do you even do physics
subconsciously that sounds like a very
difficult thing to do
so
no equations do not pour out onto the
page that's just not how it works really
i wish it worked like that but there are
the equate the equations are like the
quintessential paradigmatic example of
needing your
system two needing your conscious
cognition to to kick in um but you can
have states where
it's sort of like you know when you're
puzzling over something and you go to
sleep and then you wake up with the
answer
there's the waking version of that
you can be so absorbed in a problem and
sort of thinking about it
in such a pre-cognitive way that you
make progress and it's sort of
quasi-visualizing quasi-feeling quasi
just letting everything go
the difference is that unlike playing a
musical instrument at the end of that
process
you better have an equation or at least
an idea that leads to an equation right
i mean that's that's the difference
something like theoretical physics is at
its best
a give and take a dynamic
back and forth between the sort of
subconscious flow state and
writing equation because once you write
the equations you say all right i need
to integrate this expression
uh there's no
being in the zone for doing an integral
you got to follow the steps that's
that's all i can say
okay mark smith says if the branch of
the wave function you're experiencing
cannot interact with other branches
then what makes the actual existence of
the other branches more likely than
their non-existence
well
again i've said this before i'll try to
say it again in as compact and
understandable way as possible
the other the existence of other
branches is predicted by the schrodinger
equation and the schrodinger equation
works
that's the short answer
the real question the sort of question
you should be asking is
why in the world and how in the world
would you get rid of the other branches
of the wave function i mean it's
perfectly clear and unambiguous and
uncontroversial that they are predicted
by the schrodinger equation right
when we observe things in quantum
mechanics the measurement outcomes are
not
naively what you would predict by the
schrodinger equation because the wave
function appears to collapse and everett
has a very clear story about decoherence
and how that works
but everett also implies that by taking
the schrodinger equation seriously at
all times the other branches are there
because that's what the schrodinger
equation says
so if you don't want to believe in them
the burden is on you
to tell me why they're not there
to how you're going to change or
add to
or subtract from the schrodinger
equation to get rid of them and that's
exactly what people do you know
spontaneous collapse models literally
subtract branches from the predictions
of the schrodinger equation
hidden variable models literally add
pointers that say this is the real
branch this is the one that actually
exists okay whereas everett just says
there's just what the schrodinger
equation says that's all we accept
simon carter says what's the latest
regarding your book writing if memory
uh
sorry i'm
i'm hesitating because my my british
publisher
uh is i thought was named simon carter
for a second but it's actually sam
carter so this is not secretly my
publisher nudging me about my book
writing so sorry to confuse you about
that simon
what's the latest regarding your book
writing if memory serves you have put
back the book on complexity and
currently writing a big ideas book based
on your youtube videos and a quantum
mechanics textbook so yes as i said i
think in the previous
ama i i shouldn't really say what books
i'm working on ahead of time it's bad
karma or something like that but it's
too late now the cat's out of the bag so
short answer is yes right now i'm
splitting my book writing time between
the biggest ideas in the universe which
will be a three
book
collection volume one classical volume 2
quantum volume 3
complex and the quantum mechanics
textbook so those are my priorities
right now i have many other books that
will be written don't you worry but i
gotta worry about a finite number of
them at a time
okay grouping two questions together
one is from ezra parzabak who says do
you think china assuming they continue
to rise in economic and scientific
standing will eventually build the next
level particle collider and one from
carlos nunez who says what is your
opinion on the rise of china should the
u.s use adversarial policies to try to
impede them from achieving top
superpower status so the first question
i think the short answer is
yeah i think it's quite likely that
china will build the next level particle
collider i mean they seem to want to do
it they have the money to do it
um
why not i mean that's the nice thing
about being an authoritarian
dictatorship is if the dictator decides
to do something they can get things done
it's not necessarily good for everyone
else in the country but you can
certainly get things done and you have
the resources to do it
um as to whether the u.s should try to
impede them using adversarial policies
i don't think that's really the right
angle to take on asking the question
okay
um
because it's it makes it sound like the
bad thing is some other country being
the top superpower i don't think it's
anything intrinsically bad about some
other country than the united states
being the top superpower after all if i
lived in iceland
i might complain about things the united
states did
but i wouldn't feel that the united
states was a threat to my my status as a
functioning democracy being in iceland
or being in canada or being wherever
right
not every country needs to aspire to
being the top superpower and it's
perfectly okay to not be the top
superpower the problem with china is not
that it's potentially the top superpower
it's that it's an authoritarian
dictatorship
it is a model of
governance that is not nearly as good
for the people living in it as uh
democratic republicanism is
so
that's what i worry about
i worry not that china is going to be
more economically powerful but that they
will
spread a political
system um to cut to other countries that
eventually results in a worse off life
and set of rights uh for other people as
we're seeing in hong kong and elsewhere
right now
um
so what should the united states do
about it i have no idea i mean that's
the tricky thing like
so given the reason why i'm sort of not
exactly answering your question is um
if the concern of the united states were
just we don't want anyone else to be the
biggest economic superpower
then i can imagine certain adversarial
policies to make that happen but that's
not what i care about i care about the
spread of democracy throughout the world
and how to stop china
from spreading totalitarianism
throughout the world is a much trickier
thing in my mind than just keeping up
with them economically so you know the
single best thing that the united states
can do is not be an adversary to china
but to be a preferable role model right
to be an example of a functioning
democracy that other countries look up
to
sadly we've been bad at that
in recent years so uh i would say forget
about china just get our own house in
order be like that person we talked
about earlier who is in a bad
relationship and wondering how much work
they should do to keep it going just
worry about yourself first
okay matt hickman says how does time
reversal symmetry work for classical
black holes specifically a situation
where a test particle just crosses the
event horizon so there's a short answer
here because the classical black hole is
itself
not time reversal invariant okay a
classical black hole is much like a
melting ice cube in a glass of water the
underlying laws of physics are time
reversal invariant but the black hole
the creation of the black hole increases
entropy just like the ice cube melting
there is so so sorry so to complete that
thought
there's no surprise then that the
behavior of test particles in the
vicinity of a black hole is not time
symmetric you can cross into the event
horizon but not cross out of it
there is just as there is for the ice
cube a solution to the equations of
motion that is the time reverse
for the case of the ice cube it would be
a cool glass of water
evolving into an ice cube in a warm
glass of water unlikely but it obeys the
equations at the fundamental level
for a black hole that would be a white
hole
a white hole is just a black hole time
reversed and there for a white hole test
particles can cross out of the event
horizon but not go back in
so the whole set of possibilities is
completely symmetric there are black
holes where you go in but not out there
are white holes where you can go out but
not in
matt hoberland says in the past your
guest's audio quality has been
consistently terrific but recently there
have been a few episodes in which the
guest's audio quality is not as good did
something procedural change
um so i recognize that that's true and
no nothing procedural has changed it is
a random fluctuation uh it turns out
that audio quality is a tricky
multi-variable thing and
many things can go slightly wrong i
think you're right that there have been
a few episodes recently where the
quality was not as good
trust me i care a lot about getting the
audio quality good and i'm gonna keep
trying to make it as good as possible um
but many things can get in the way
i do send my guests at a microphone
sometimes they don't want a microphone
sometimes they have a microphone they
think is just as good that's fine um but
what what has happened i think just just
coincidentally again no systemic reason
recently is that people have had good
microphones but they've been in really
echoey environments
as i say that sitting in this apartment
in boston i worry that i'm in a very
echoey environment so i hope this isn't
very bad but i think i can control it a
little bit but um you know literally i
had a guest who
was in the process of moving out of
their office i'm not going to say who
and so like there were no books or
anything in the office it was just an
empty room and we had literally tested
the audio quality ahead of time but in a
different room and they moved to an
empty room before recording the podcast
uh a week later and then
there was an echo what can i do so
all i can say is i am learning
uh more and more things that can go
wrong with the audio quality and
hopefully this leads me to be better and
better at preventing those things from
going wrong
liam applebus says in the episode with
brian arthur about complexity economics
you asked if he was worried that his
computational approach would be missing
the deeper understanding you can get
from an equation-based approach
what is it about equation-based
approaches that gives a deeper
understanding if you mean intuitive
level of understanding surely you can
get that from watching a simulation
so this is a good question what i mean
is just that
an equation
in principle in practice that can be
hard but in principle an equation
captures every possible simulation
simulations are done one by one right
you do okay you simulate this
configuration and then that one and you
can try to span the space of all
possibilities and you realize ah when i
change this this change is okay
but
an equation in again in principle
contains all the possible things that
can happen it's a rule right so if i say
that gravity is an inverse square law
i instantly know not only how planets
move around the sun but also how apples
fall from trees
whereas if i just do a bunch of
simulations and see planets moving in
ellipses i say oh look planets move an
ellipses doesn't tell me about apples
falling from trees the equation
instantly
spreads to all these different
situations that's why i think that it
can in principle once again give you a
more intuitive level of understanding
niles darg asks a priority question
i love your thoughts on my
interpretation the speed of light is the
maximum processing power of the universe
time moves forward constantly at the
speed of light bringing everything with
it but when an object approaches c the
universe struggles to facilitate its
travel through time causing dilation
similarly time dilation is experienced
near a black hole because there is so
much information being processed in such
a condensed space
so i'm going to do something very
dangerous here niles and i'm going to
try to give you my best answer
the reason why this is dangerous is
because you know it's always very
possible that 50 years from now we have
a much deeper understanding of these
things and my answer turns out to be
completely wrong but my answer is uh i
don't like your interpretation sorry
about that
for a couple reasons one is you start by
saying time moves forward constantly at
c
but it doesn't
what does that mean time does not move
at the speed of light the speed of light
is the speed at which light moves
moving in this sense is traversing a
certain amount of distance per unit time
that's why we measure the speed of light
in something like meters per second
time
does not traverse distance
much less traversing distance in any
particular
amount of time
time traverses time so you can say how
much time passes per unit time the
answer is always one second per second
i've said this before i literally wrote
that in my draft for the biggest ideas
book just the other day that's the rate
at which time flows one one second per
second always there's literally no other
rate which it possibly could flow at
okay
so you say then
when an object approaches the speed of
light the universe struggles to
facilitate its travel through time
well
um and this is why i hesitate my what i
said about time is just true but this is
a little bit trickier because
according to the theory of relativity
what you just said can't be right
because you're saying that uh the
universe struggles to facilitate travel
through time when an object approaches
the speed of light but in relativity
there's no such thing as approaching the
speed of light as an absolute sense
there is the relative velocity of two
different objects approaching the speed
of light but i can always switch to the
rest frame of any object i want so if
one object is approaching the speed of
light i can just go to its rest frame
and it's stationary
in its rest frame so the idea that the
universe struggles
to
operate one way for one particle moving
in one trajectory and a different
rate for another particle moving on
another one is incompatible with the
spirit of relativity that says all such
trajectories are created equal okay
um now you know maybe relativity will be
superseded one day and things will be
different but that's what i would say is
probably true right now
cooper says is there a sense in which
entanglement can travel at different
speeds through the environment for
example inside schrodinger's cat's box
the photons and gaseous matter quickly
entangle but then entanglement slowly
propagates outward due to the solid less
interactive matter making up the walls
is it true that you could cool a
material down close to absolute zero to
act as entanglement shield
really should have put this back up
there in the in the entanglement
question but but i think i've already
answered it um
yes there is a sense in which
entanglement travels at different speeds
through the environment i guess the
reason why i isolated the question is
because for those of you who are
interested there is a mathematical
result called the lieb robinson bound
elliott lieb l-i-e-b robinson don't know
their first name um they made a bound on
the rate at which entanglement travels
uh through a quantum system and you can
look that up but it depends on the
details it depends on the materials that
you're constructed of the hamiltonian or
the interactions or whatever it is but
yes and then you can take advantage of
this different rate of entanglement
spreading um to shield things from
becoming entanglement and that's what
you need to do if you build a quantum
computer
arthur c quark probably not their real
name says could you elaborate on the
difference between causality and
determinism and what role entropy plays
causality says that e
implies
so
i'm not quite sure what the language is
saying here causality arrow implies that
a causes b but b does not cause a
determinism arrow if you know the state
of system at any time and the laws of
that system you can calculate the state
of that system at any other time future
or past
um for example arthur continues if i
were to watch the movie of a perfectly
elastic frictionless billiard table
without holes i wouldn't tell if the
table if the movie were being played
forward or backwards therefore i can't
say with certainty what caused what to
happen however i could calculate what
the table looked like in every frame of
the movie if i really wanted to if
that's right is it still true for
something more complex like scrambling
eggs or stirring cream into coffee
so
this is a complicated question this is
literally something i'm trying to write
papers about right now and the reason
why it's complicated is because it's a
question of emergence once again
determinism in our current way of
understanding the universe this is not a
statement about every possible universe
but the real world um determinism is
something that seems to be found at the
micro level right billiard balls
something like that small numbers of
moving pieces
at the emergent level at higher levels
we're throwing away information okay
that's what emergence is all about
there's many different micro states that
that look the same as far as macro
states are concerned and therefore it is
often the case that the immersion theory
is not deterministic and there is an
arrow of time okay
so
what i would say is
there's no reason to ever use words like
causality at the micro level causality
at least in the classical sense that
aristotle would have understood formal
causes etc um is a strictly macroscopic
phenomenon and it is a time directed
phenomenon the causes never come after
the effects
whereas in micro physics which aristotle
didn't know about at the time we have
reversibility determinism laplace's
demon and so forth so nothing is time
directed at the deterministic reversible
microphysical level therefore you
shouldn't talk about causality the
interesting thing is to ask why when you
do coarse grain and go from the micro
level to the macro level you have
something called causality that does
play an important role and is a useful
concept and that's tricky and i don't
have a complete story to tell about it
um but it will ultimately involve coarse
graining and entropy and
all sorts of interesting things that
involve both philosophy and physics and
computer science and stuff like that
joshua hillerup says i know you aren't
an expert in this but from my
understanding you do talk to all sorts
of experts so i'm wondering is there
actually a way out of this pandemic
given things like the delta variant
reinfecting people over and over again
and new strains developing all the time
are we ever going to be able to live in
a society that can open up again without
sending massive numbers of people to the
hospital or dying
yeah so i'm not an expert so no one
should take my opinion about this
seriously you should listen to the
experts but i'm a human being and i do
think about these things these are
important questions right
um
you know i think that the
most obvious long-term
situation to be in and it's far from
completely obvious but like the first
thing you would guess is that
uh
the coronavirus the novel coronavirus
that as we used to call it
sars covid19
is uh going to be like the flu but worse
so the flu is a set of viruses a wide
variety of different kinds of viruses
uh that mutate and so there's different
kinds of flu every year and thousands of
people die every year and there are
shots you can get and some people get
them and some people don't
and the number of people who die every
year is sort of just small enough that
we don't really go crazy about it okay
the number of people dying from covet is
much larger than that and i don't think
we would put up with it
uh if you know
half a million people died in the united
states every year going forward as a as
a rule like that would be that would be
bad we would sort of not put up with it
in the way that we put up with the flu
but you can imagine a sort of
quasi-equilibrium
where we fight it but not very
effectively so many people get
vaccinated but not everyone does
um
the new variants keep appearing and we
we get booster shots to fight them but
not everyone gets them etc
and every year
a hundred thousand people die in the
united states of covet or covet variance
that's a possible future it's not a good
one i don't love it
um but it's possible and in that in that
future
some people will continue to wear masks
socially distance other people will not
it'll be like uh
almost what we have now but a little bit
better that's what that's what a very
logical thing could be
we could get our act together get
everyone vaccinated and like everyone in
the world it's not enough because the
countries are semi-permeable membranes
so our goodness sorry are completely
permeable membranes so getting one
country vaccinated is not enough if you
get the world vaccinated
you can imagine stamping it out
right we have stamped out other diseases
smallpox and things like that
um by getting really good vaccines
if there aren't enough
new people to be infected the virus will
die out um i just don't
right now as i'm saying this i'm not at
all sure that we have the willpower to
do that and a lot of people just don't
want to get vaccinated at all so
um
i'm not sure that's uh the that happy
scenario is going to come true
there is also much worse scenarios right
i mean like you say there are other
variants
uh in some sense we were really really
lucky believe it or not with the
coronavirus that uh it wasn't much more
deadly you know the the tricky thing
about the coronavirus was that it has a
long incubation period relatively
speaking you can have it
and be contagious but not be symptomatic
which is half of the ingredients for a
truly
world-threatening viral plague okay the
other half is everyone who gets it dies
if that were true like the the worst
possible virus would be one where
everyone gets it so it's super duper
transmissible okay it's very very
contagious and when you get it you get
no symptoms for a month or for six
months
and then
six months after you you get it you die
with 100 probability right that kind of
virus if it were to exist uh would wipe
out humanity on earth um it's probably
not gonna be that bad don't get too
frightened by it
it's unlikely that some variant of the
coronavirus is going to be 100 fatal and
we're pretty good at developing vaccines
now so we can protect against it
but some version of that
is possible so if the median is
it's kind of like the flu but worse
the
high level hopeful future is we stamp it
out
then the terrible apocalyptic future is
it just there's a variant of it which is
much much more deadly and kills millions
and millions and millions of people
i think all of these are on the table
and the longer we go without wiping it
out
the more chance there is to develop into
a much more virulent deadly variant
i will say again i am not an expert in
this so
let that be provocation for your own
thoughts but listen to the real experts
if you actually want to know what's
going to happen i just haven't talked to
one
recently about this exact question so
i'm just spitballing not giving you
expert um knowledge here
eugene ilovsky says were you a math
prodigy who turned to physics or a
physics prodigy who could do the
necessary math
um so i will demure on the question of
whether i was a prodigy at all uh but i
did fall in love with physics very early
and it was physics that i fell in love
with and you know not every decision you
make when you're 10 years old turns out
to be the right one but for me that was
the right one i've learned a lot of math
subsequently but math is not my passion
like if it doesn't help me understand
the world i get you know kind of tired
i'll have it pretty quickly like you
know you can follow steven strogatz
former mindscape guest on twitter and
he's great you know he's just a great
twitter follow uh very good at
explaining things and very uh
entertaining and so forth but man he
loves these little math puzzles and i
just look at him like i don't care
it just doesn't do it for me like what
am i helping to understand by thinking
about this i can't think of anything so
and it's good that we're different in
that way it's good that there are both
physicists and mathematicians but for me
physics easy call
charlie h says i really admire the way
you have great discussions with experts
from all fields on mindscape
what if anything have you found to be a
key or significant difference between
the mindscape of sciency guests from
that of humanistic-y guests
that's a good question and to be honest
i have never thought about it i've never
really sort of uh looked for um
commonalities between those two groups
um so there might be ones that i haven't
thought of so i'm not gonna give you a
very uh comprehensive reliable answer
here
um and in fact as as
you might have noticed i have noticed
i'm constantly in the situation of
interviewing someone who is not a
physicist and and them telling me oh
yeah i was a physics major as an
undergraduate or something like that so
even the humanistic people who i uh
interview sometimes have like secret
physics and sympathies so there's a huge
selection effect in who i am picking
right
but also there's a selection effect in
which scientists i'm picking because i
tend to pick scientists who have broader
interests interdisciplinary interests
etc so i don't see a huge difference
between them but i'm picking humanists
who are
tend to be science
uh friendly and also scientists who tend
to be humanities friendly so maybe it's
not such a big surprise there
i mean obviously there's like trivial
differences
scientists are more likely to try to
want to write down equations
or do experiments than humanists are but
i think that the general mindset
is more or less similar
christopher said you once said on joe
rogan's podcast that you think cities
are good for the planet could you
explain uh expand on that at all
yeah uh but mostly i would point you to
an earlier podcast i did with joe
walston on urbanization and the
environment and he's the one who
convinced me of this i've heard rumbles
about it before but joe wilson is a
conservationist by trade so he's he's
literally invested in conserving the
environment uh and he gives the world's
best sales pitch for cities because look
given a certain number of people in a
certain amount of economic activity
there's roughly speaking two extremes
one is you spread those people in that
activity uniformly across the land and
you sort of despoil all of the land
because there's people everywhere
or you concentrate
those people and that activity in a
small number of locations and you leave
the rest of the land for the planet and
the environment and the ecology
guess which one is better
and those concentrations of people and
activity are called cities that's what
they are
at a very basic way a basic very basic
level
you need fewer natural resources to live
in a city than you do in the country you
don't drive as far
it's much like look where i am right now
in this apartment building in boston
right downtown there are other apartment
units on
most sides of my building so guess what
if i heat it or cool it
i'm not then ejecting that heat
differential right into the environment
i'm sharing it with other human beings
right next to me so it costs less
it's much better for the environment in
terms of resources etc if human beings
limit the fraction of the earth's
surface that they take over roughly
speaking that's the point
anonymous says what would happen if you
put one end of an arbitrarily strong and
arbitrarily long cord into one black
hole and the other end into another
black hole would the black holes be
pulled together
so
a couple quick thoughts here one is
especially in relativity but even more
generally in physics
as soon as you say words like or phrases
like arbitrarily strong and arbitrarily
long
you're gonna get into trouble
arbitrarily long okay but arbitrarily
strong chords are not really physical
right um roughly speaking and again
there's details here that i'm not gonna
get into but roughly speaking the
stronger more rigid
um a rod or a cord is the faster sound
travels down it and you don't want your
sound speed in your cord to be faster
than the speed of light
you want it when you tug at one end
nothing happens to the other end until
the speed of light has has passed
or until a signal moving the speed of
light could get there
so
it's a little bit unphysical to imagine
these things but i get what you mean
um the reason why it's a hard question
to answer is that if you have the black
holes and there's nothing else in the
universe
then even without the cord they're going
to be pulled together they have gravity
right the gravity will pull them
together so i believe i'm not 100
certain about this but i believe adding
the chord in there will pull them
together a little bit faster because
roughly speaking they're pulling on the
chord as well as the other black hole um
but it's not a qualitative difference in
the behavior
okay i'm going to group two questions
together
brent meeker says in mindscape 63 on
finding gravity within quantum mechanics
you speculated that there are only
finitely many degrees of freedom in a
given volume of space wouldn't this
imply that there are also only finite
many possible states and so there will
be a smallest non-zero probability of
any possible event
andrew k says due to beckenstein's bound
in a finite volume of space there can
only be a finite number of bits of
information however in quantum mechanics
real numbers are used all over the place
is it worthwhile to try to replace these
real numbers with rational numbers in
order to only require a finite number of
bits to represent them so both these
questions are getting at the following
idea that um
the entropy of a black hole let's put it
this way there's different ways of
stating the same answer but the entropy
of a black hole as beckenstein hawking
taught us is a finite number
whereas the entanglement entropy
of a region of space and quantum field
theory remember we talked about quant
entanglement entropy and if i just take
a region of space and think of the
quantum fields inside that region they
are automatically entangled with quantum
fields outside that region
that entropy they have an entropy the
quantum fields inside a region have an
entropy because of entanglement and if
you naively calculated it you get
infinity
and that's because there's an infinite
number of ways to arrange what's
happening in a region of space because
quantum field theory has an infinite
number of degrees of freedom
so the fact that
black holes have a finite entropy
and yet we think that black holes are
maximum entropy for a given volume
i said before that black holes are not
maximum entropy but they are maximum
entropy fixed volume okay and if you
don't fix the volume then you can always
expand the entropy by expanding the
volume of space but for a fixed volume
black holes are the highest entropy you
can get and it's not infinite
that seems to indicate the quantum field
theory is wrong
and that there is some
finite dimensional quantum mechanical
system that describes what go what goes
on inside the black hole that's not 100
accurate because it's a sloppy kind of
reasoning but it's very plausible and i
i suspect it's right i suspect it's on
the right track
but let me distinguish between two
things i think both questions are are
mixing up two different possibilities um
there's the number of degrees of freedom
in the sense of the number of dimensions
of hilbert space the number of specific
different
directions in which your quantum state
can point okay if i have a single
spinning particle a single electron its
spin
is described by a two dimensional
hilbert space
spin up or spin down the cat in
schrodinger's cat also two-dimensional
hilbert space awake or asleep obviously
there's many more degrees of freedom in
the cat but we're ignoring them okay
if i have two particles that are
spinning i have four degrees four
dimensions of hilbert's space two times
2 is 4. if i have n particles it's 2 to
the n dimensions
but so that's a finite dimensional
hilbert space if if that system of a
finite number of spins were entangled it
would have a finite entropy okay not an
infinite entropy but that's very
different than the fact that each
individual
spin
has a wave function that is a
superposition of spin up and spin down
and the amplitudes of that superposition
are continuous
they are not discrete okay that's not
the idea that there's only a discrete
set of probabilities that you could have
for spin up or spin down
is not part of quantum mechanics not
part of anyone's version of quantum
mechanics you could try to invent one
people have tried but whatever you're
doing is you're you're not doing what
quantum mechanics says so the finitude
of either entanglement entropy in
general or of the black hole entropy
is the number of degrees of freedom but
it's not a discreteness of the wave
function it's just the wave function is
a function of
a finite number of variables instead of
an infinite number of variables but the
values that it can take on each one of
those variables are still continuous
not discrete i hope that's clear it's a
little bit more technical than i usually
get here but given the questions that
were being asked i hope that you can
understand
okay
jim murphy asks a priority question
i'm basically wondering whether the
order of moments in time is necessarily
fundamental could all moments of time
exist independently without reference to
moments before and after
i imagine the universe existing as a
mathematical set of possible states and
time emerges from the fact that some
states contain references to other
states for example my brain right now
contains memories of a brain a few
seconds ago
this seems similar to your explanation
for our perception of the flow of time
but your explanation still assumes a
blocked universe rather than a
collection of unconnected moments
um so honestly i'm just not sure
what it would mean
for the order of moments in time to not
be
fundamental
especially if they're an infinite number
of them a smooth continuum of them which
i think there probably are but we don't
know for sure so i'm going to leave that
aside um let me say things i think are
true and hopefully they will address
your concerns rather than trying to
guess what your concern is
we live in a universe that has two
features
that have to do with time one is
continuity
so what we mean by that is
there are equations that tell us whether
it's newton or maxwell or einstein or
whatever but given what the universe is
doing at one moment of time the way the
laws of physics work is that they tell
you what will happen at exactly the next
moment
they are differential equations in time
in particular okay so they describe a
smooth evolution of the state of the
universe from one moment to another
so in that sense
uh
you could rearrange or or ignore the
ordering of the moments but that would
be dumb
that would be that'll be very bad
strategically uh because then it's hard
to say what the laws of physics are even
telling you right the laws of physics as
we know them
relate moments of time in a very
specific order okay that's one fact the
other fact is like you say the arrow of
time um
and the it's a little bit it's a little
bit tricky the subtle the relationship
here because because of determinism and
reversibility
if your laplace's demon if you know the
microstates
then the entire future and past are
let's say that you're ever reading about
quantum mechanics too so there's no
fundamental indeterminism in quantum
mechanics the entire future and past are
implicit in every moment to laplace's
demon okay so in that sense
laplace's demon has perfect memories and
perfect predictions
uh at the macroscopic level for we
emergent non-laplace's demons we have
memories of the past and not of the
future that that's an asymmetry that
that shows up okay so when you say my
brain right now contains memories of a
brain a few seconds ago
that's a time directed statement your
brain right now does not contain
memories of a few seconds from now and
the reason why that asymmetry exists is
because entropy
is increasing okay
so
that is i mean what i want to say about
this is it's not fundamental that fact
that your brain quote unquote contains
memories of a brain a few seconds ago is
a statement at the emergent approximate
macroscopic level
at the microscopic level your brain
right now contains exact or at least
some
broad swath of the universe maybe a few
light minutes across centered on your
brain contains the information that
determines
both your brain a few seconds ago and
your brain a few seconds in the future
so there's no directionality there at
the microscopic level so there's a
temptation
to think of something being contained in
your brain
that relates to the past but not the
present but that's only because we only
have access to the macroscopic level if
we had micro information we'd have equal
information forward and backward so what
this has to do with moments of time
existing independently without moments
before and after you know again
you're welcome to do that but it seems
to me to be a huge step backwards in
convenience and understandability the
world is intelligible because we can
predict what will happen at the next
moment from what is happening right now
mike maloney says you mentioned that the
traditional scientific oh am i grouping
two questions together i am grouping two
questions together mike maloney says you
mentioned that the traditional
scientific method is not the way
professional scientists actually do
science as a science teacher i was
wondering if you could think there was
some other kind of method we could be
teaching middle school and high school
students that would be better that would
better prepare them for careers in
science
and rasmus keith nirbeck says in your
opinion what would be the most important
thing to teach in schools regarding
science in general or physics in
particular that are now missing from the
general curriculum i do know that both
teaching methods and curriculum is
somewhat different from your co in your
country to mine but still interested in
your opinion from a physics professor's
view so i think that rasmus you're
probably looking for some
thing like quantum mechanics or
relativity or entropy or some physics
concept um i do generally think that we
are too reluctant to teach fun modern
cool physics
in high school and uh
middle school you know i think that we
will teach newton's laws maybe a little
bit of electricity and magnetism or
something like that
but we're not going to teach general
relativity the equations are too scary i
don't see any reason why we shouldn't do
at least a descriptive
non-equation-based
explanation of these modern physics
ideas even in high school
but my real answer to your question is
also the answer to the previous question
because what i would really want to
teach
kids in high school and in middle school
is the scientific is the is
not the scientific method but the real
the real method by which science is done
not what we typically label the
scientific method for those of you who
don't know
what is often labeled the scientific
method in high school science courses
is this uh fairly
formalized procedure that goes back to
francis bacon and his friends
of doing science whereby you propose a
hypothesis devise a test for your
hypothesis collect the data determine
whether your hypothesis passed the test
etc
it's
vaguely related to what scientists
actually do but any real scientist knows
that real science is way messier than
that and so i think the two things that
i would like to get across
to high school students about the real
way science is done is number one that
there is a procedure that is highly
fallibilistic
it's not an algorithm for getting the
truth um it's absolutely uh i mean
science is
basically a highly formalized version of
trial and error
it's imagine many different
possibilities the hypotheses and assign
to them in a good bayesian way you don't
need to necessarily use this language in
high school students but you could um
assign prior credences to them simpler
theories would get higher credences more
complicated ones would get lower
credences but they would all get
non-zero credence then you collect data
and they change your credences but you
could always be wrong i mean both your
assignment acquiences could be wrong
your calculation of likelihoods can be
wrong and most importantly your data
could be wrong like have you ever done a
laboratory experiment in high school and
gotten the wrong answer
i have i think most people probably have
that's an important part of doing
science it's not a collection of facts
it is a process and it's a process that
is highly
fallibilistic and the other aspect i
would want to emphasize is that it's not
even an orderly
process you know the the scientific
method we're taught the bocconian
scientifica method seems to you know say
you need to first write down your
hypothesis etc no one really does that
it's a constant back and forth between
observations experiments ideas
you're constantly spiraling or
dialoguing let's put it that way
between the real world and your thoughts
about the real world and that's okay
it's not you know against the rules or
anything like that and i would like to
explain that to high school students if
i could
okay
mystery horse says given all of your
success i'm curious if you've abandoned
ideas papers books or other projects
that you invested a significant amount
of energy into
if so could you tell us about a
particular failed idea that contributed
to a successful future one
um yeah i mean that happens all the time
actually but then this is not i mean i
think that i'm
slower than many scientists in the sense
that i will often get an idea
and want to do it and uh it'll take me a
long time
years before i actually do something
about it this happens all the time um
this paper i wrote with aidan chatwin
davies on
the relationship between the second law
of thermodynamics and the expansion of
the universe i had that idea years
before i was convinced
that the second law and the cosmic
no-hair theorem had to be related in
some way uh and it wasn't i would
occasionally tell my graduate students
this and they go yeah maybe and aiden
was the one who's actually able to come
up with a way of proving something right
so it was never a failed idea but it was
a gestating one
my most highly cited paper is on
what is now called f of r gravity so
it's a modification of general
relativity that could possibly make the
universe accelerate i don't know if you
want to call this a failure or not but i
came up with that idea
because i was hopeful that it would
explain both dark matter and dark energy
both rotation curves of galaxies and the
acceleration of the universe so it
doesn't do that it doesn't work for
rotation curves of galaxies so i figured
that out like i said oh yes it could
make the universe accelerate but it will
not explain rotation curves of galaxies
so in my mind
it was a failure and so i didn't write
it because it didn't do what i wanted to
do and it wasn't until my collaborators
mark trodden and others uh independently
came up with the idea and said is this
interesting i'm like well i guess if
everyone else is coming up with the same
idea maybe it is interesting and we
finally wrote the paper and it became a
huge success there you go
um
other papers i had are very much like
that
there's millions of ideas probably that
i've had that have just failed and
continue to fail like have not
grown into great papers but i tend to
just not remember them very well so i'm
not going to tell you any
charlie grover says
suppose one has a scalar field slowly
rolling toward the minimum of its
potential a concrete example of this
would be a quintessence field
it's commonly said excitations of a
quintessence field have a mass maybe
around 10 to the minus 33 electron volts
what does it mean for excitations of the
scalar field to have a specific mass
while it is rolling
clearly okay there's a longer question
but so what's going on is the following
imagine you have a scalar field so
you're picturing in your head
a
potential a hill right a landscape and
the
but the scalar field is a dot that is
rolling down that potential and
typically most scalar fields like the
higgs boson is a scalar field pions are
scalar fields axions would be scalar
fields if they existed we haven't found
any yet but there you go
the mass of the scalar field is related
to the curvature of the potential near
its minimum okay
because
if you think about it so you have a
minimum of a potential
so there's some value that the potential
has and then it has a first derivative
the slope but the slope is always
exactly zero because you're at the
minimum we told you you're at the
minimum so the slope of the potential is
zero the next interesting thing is the
curvature the second derivative of the
potential
and that is basically telling you how
much energy it costs to nudge the scalar
field a little bit away from the minimum
minimum of its potential and that energy
cost
shows up in particle physics language as
the mass of the particle that you're
looking at so the relationship between
the mass of a particle
and the potential of the field that
defines that particle is the mass is
given by the second derivative or really
the square root of the second derivative
of the potential near its minimum now
for a quintessence field quintessence is
a candidate for dark energy that is a
slowly rolling scalar field and by slow
we mean it takes longer than the current
age of the universe to roll down its
potential
and what that means is
unlike the higgs or the axion or the
pion this field is not sitting at the
bottom of its potential so it has a
bottom of the potential is just not
there yet hasn't gotten there yet takes
longer in the age of the universe to get
there
so you're completely correct
charlie when we say that we will often
talk about the mass of the quintessence
field as if it were sitting there at the
bottom of its potential and calculating
the second derivative
that's cheating
we shouldn't really do that
when it's somewhere else on the
potential what you should do
is expand calculate the second
derivative there wherever it is okay not
at the minimum
and if it if it is at the minimum then
the value of the second derivative
somewhere else is just not an
interesting quantity but if it's rolling
slowly and hasn't gotten to the minimum
yet then the value of the second
derivative where it is
acts as the mass
it acts as the mass in the equations of
motion for the scalar field however the
reason why no one really makes a big
deal about this is
for a typical
choice of potential for a choice of
potential that you haven't finely tuned
in some way
it will more often than not be the case
that the order of magnitude of the
second derivative
is the same wherever the field is as it
will be once it gets to the minimum that
it's obvious counter example to this
which is a field that just rolls off
forever okay that doesn't even have a
minimum but for a typical field that is
just generically rolling the magnitude
of the second derivative has a value
that is comparable same order of
magnitude um so therefore
talking about the mass is sort of a
proxy
sort of a
quick and dirty way of getting at
how strongly the potential is changing
as the field value changes that's all so
it's just sloppiness that's the gave you
a long answer the short answer is we're
just being sloppy sorry about that
okay we're nearing the end folks we have
two more questions left james nencaro
says if there are many bubble universes
as an eternal inflation and our universe
is one of those and the bubble universes
are of various random sizes and larger
universes are less likely than smaller
ones does this provide a solution to the
fermi paradox why we don't see alien
civilizations or their probes in our
neighborhood
um
i don't think so no i mean i get the
idea that uh you know
you
if you have many many different bubble
universes
the probability of getting even one
civilization
per universe can be very small
and yet you're going to get a lot of
civilizations because there's a lot of
bubble universes right
so in that scenario you would as i think
james you're getting at you would
predict that each civilization is alone
in its uh region of space
um but the but the point is you don't
really need the multiverse for that so i
mean i think that logic is completely
good it might even be correct
but you don't need the features of
eternal inflation or bubble universes
where like the laws of physics are
different or anything like that you
could just imagine that our universe is
really really big and the probability of
life forming an intelligent
civilization's forming is very very
small
and then you explain the fermi paradox
right so you need that in your scenario
i'm calling it your scenario but
uh you you need other things in your
scenario all these bubble universes in
my scenario you just say the probability
of life for intelligent civilizations is
very small
that's it
now we're here right so you might want
to say well if the probability of life
is very small maybe the probability of
us being here is very small but
this is again a longer more uh nuanced
discussion but i think you should just
conditionalize on us being here we
already know we're here this is what
bayesians call old evidence we shouldn't
count it again uh there's no theory we
should be paying attention to that
predicts we're not here
right that we we've already taken into
account the fact that we're here
whenever we do any of this reasoning
about anything so our existence i would
argue
counts for strictly nothing when we're
talking about the different
probabilities of different theories of
the universe so as long as
the probability of life forming is small
then
forgetting about us the question we're
asking is what is the probability of
life or or technologically advanced life
forming somewhere else and the answer
will be it'll be small if it if the
original number is sufficiently tiny
okay the last question
another bit of a curveball here gabor
peter serre says
looking at the failure in afghanistan
what do you think would be an effective
way how western democracies could help
countries with strong influence of
religious extremists
if the goal is building a society where
human rights are respected more would
strengthening secular education in favor
of religious education help
um yeah so again to people
a century from now listening to the old
mindscape archives
we just had the american withdrawal from
afghanistan um
not quite two decades but but close to
two decades after we invaded there after
the september 11th attacks
and you know tensions are running high
right now i don't want to step on
anyone's toes on the one hand you have a
bunch of people who say look
we get into these wars
to try to fix a whole country
and it there's no end game right there's
no
surrender or anything like that that
we're looking for the goal is is
nominally to
transform a nation but that's really
hard so we end up just staying there and
people keep dying and nothing really
good happens
there are other people and so therefore
we should leave is is their argument and
the other people say look there are
really bad things happening in the world
human rights violations dictatorships
atrocities of various forms
nurturing terrorists that can attack
other countries etc
and we as the superpower have an
obligation this side says to go in there
and stop that from happening and as john
mccain famously said when he was running
for president he would be willing to
stay there for thousands of years if
that's what it took to like
tamp down
the uh violence and the extremism in
those countries
so there's one school of thought that
says we shouldn't go in at all and
another one says we should stay for
thousands of years
and we recently were there for 20 years
when we left or 17 or 19 years or
whatever it was and it's been kind of a
mess to be very
polite about it you know again people
disagree and temp tempers run high but
um it's been a mess let's just put it
that way the withdrawal has been a mess
and so again one side says well
yeah it was going to be a mess there's
nothing you could do like it was a
you had your finger in the dike and
you're saying what's going to happen if
i remove my finger well there's going to
be a flood there's just nothing else you
can do about it and the other side says
there are ways to withdraw that would
have been much better that would have
been not nearly as messy okay i'm not
going into that one either the question
that gabor is asking is
if you imagine that we go there if you
imagine that we invade a country
and you know okay we have the military
capabilities of removing its government
from power putting another government
into power
um
stopping terrorist activity or at least
fighting against it etc those things we
can do but what about the fabric
of the country like what about the fact
that
there are people in this country and i'm
not even specializing to afghanistan i'm
trying to be more general than that so
the specifics of afghanistan are again
not something i'm an expert in none of
this is stuff i'm an expert in but it's
my ama and i'm at the end of it so i'm
going to pontificate um
it's
there are people in this country this
hypothetical country who support the bad
guys right i mean otherwise they
wouldn't have gotten into power in the
first place
so
how do you not just overthrow the
government but change the fabric of the
society and the culture
so that the set of people who support
the bad guys is sufficiently small and
powerless that we don't need to be there
to um hold them down that's the question
that is being asked and the short answer
is i don't know even at this sort of
uh very loosey-goosey end of the ama
podcast episode uh letting our hair down
kind of mode um i i just have such
enormous respect for the difficulty of
this question that i think it would do a
disservice to be too glib about it how
do you change the fabric of a country
just an hour ago i said it's hard to
change the fabric of a single person
you're in a relationship with changing
the fabric of a country
is really hard to imagine doing um
having said that i will say just one
little tiny thing which is that what we
tend to do historically
is
mostly military right that's where we
focus our efforts we being the united
states in in the last century of its
history um we invade and we you know uh
keep track of military
actions by the bad guys and we try to
prevent them etc etc we're much less
good
at
creating a stable functioning society in
the non-military aspects of the country
i'm not even sure that we try very hard
we try a little bit
but the idea of better schools better
education better health care ideas that
by the way would be also nice to have in
our own country
but these ideas are just not emphasized
in these uh adventures very often
so on the one hand
could we have more success in these
adventures if we did more of that
you know maybe i i honestly don't know
um but it wouldn't hurt to try
i think that there's enough um
historical evidence that we're not able
to change countries that don't want to
be changed um
but
what we can do again just like the
question with china earlier the thing
that we have in our power to do
is to be a good example
to
you know not just say be like us to
hector the other countries and say like
you know you should be like us
but to make them want to be like us by
being awesome
by having great human rights by being
economically vibrant by protecting our
own people the poor people the less
well-off and by giving them
the way to do that right you know if if
we had somehow and i don't think it's
possible so i'm not casting aspersions
here but if we could have converted
afghanistan into a prosperous
functioning democracy we would not be in
this mess
right now that's more much more easily
said than done so again i'm not saying
that we should have just done it
snapping our fingers but it should be
the goal it should be like the
aspiration when we go into these and if
we can't
then we shouldn't linger there very very
long you know i do think the final
thought here is that
you know again
truth in history i was very much against
the invasion of iraq uh when george w
bush was president but i was in favor of
the invasion of afghanistan on the
thought that um the terrorists who were
based in afghanistan had just done a
terrible terrorist attack against us and
we should punish them somehow
but i would have been much much more in
favor of something very quick in and out
rather than an attempt to go there and
rebuild the country um go in and go out
and by all means give them aid and you
know give them resources to improve
their country and things like that we
should be doing those things anyway even
to other countries that do not harbor
terrorists that attack us so certainly
we should be doing it if we want to win
the hearts and minds of
countries where we don't want them to
support the bad guys but you know
look i'm an idealistic heart an optimist
at heart i think that there are ways
that society can be much better both
other societies and our own i don't
think that religion is the fundamental
issue here but it is an issue
it's part of the story um and if if you
want to say that my picture of what we
should do in these other countries is
hopelessly naive and it will never work
and you want to characterize your own
point of view as more realistic and
hard-nosed
very well you know you might very well
be right
i'm not an expert on this i'm just an
aspirationalist who uh
thinks that uh we should you know i'm
becoming more of a deontologist honestly
in my old age you know i'm thinking that
rather than inventing consequentialist
rules for making the world a better
place we should worry about acting in
the good ways ourselves and maybe the
world will follow us
there you go thanks for paying attention
thanks for doing this ama
see you next month and thanks very much
for supporting the mindscape podcast i
don't say it enough
but um it is tremendously warming to my
heart that as many people as do join
patreon and uh
throw in a few pennies here and there to
support this little endeavor that we all
do together thanks bye
[Music]
you